this is impossible the SCP site director
wasn't normally a calm or cheerful man
but the researcher had rarely seen him
as angry as he was right now his face
turned a deep beat red as he scanned the
documents on his desk before he asked
how months of valuable research on this
subject had suddenly gone blank the data
was completely gone the researcher
gulped nervously hoping a demotion
wasn't in his future and nodded how
could this be possible this was an
experienced researcher who should have
been taking all the necessary
precautions could the being they were
studying somehow have erased all these
documents himself that's just what the
researcher had been trying to find out
for months with hours and hours spent
trying to learn the extent of its
abilities well where are they the site
director asked I want everything you
have the researcher dropped a printout
of their research on the mysterious
subject's abilities on the director's
desk every relevant line add data lost
the director let out a deep sigh he
wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew well everything he could remember
at least from the beginning the
researchers sat down and began to relay
everything he could about
scp-343 which some of the other
researchers had started to refer to by
the nickname God
scp-343 was first cited in Prague just
an unassuming older man wandering the
streets he seemed completely normal to
everyone who passed him by until he
decided he was tired of staying on the
ground an SCP agent stationed in the
area noticed the old man disappear from
the streets as if he was blinking out of
existence only to appear on a rooftop
nearby the local SCP teams were
marshaled and they had soon Tracked Down
what seemed to be a very powerful
specimen but scp-343 didn't seem
concerned he reacted calmly when
detained by the foundation and went with
him willingly he was detained in a
standard holding cell for interrogation
and examination but he seemed completely
at ease with his sudden confinement who
would soon become clear that this
ordinary old man was anything but
doctors Becca nidlavu was brought in to
consult on the scp's classification and
that's when the first anomalies began
their assessments matched initially but
when it came time to describe him
physically things took a strange turn
older male seemingly non-descript and
with no unusual physical features
Caucasian in appearance Dr nidlovu was
confused by what Dr Beck was describing
in his report this man was clearly black
the two doctors quarreled unable to
square their differing perceptions they
decided to bring in a third impartial
view to settle it their fellow
researcher Dr Wan she didn't take long
before coming back with her assessment
older male seemingly nondescript and
with no unusual physical features Asian
in appearance possibly Chinese whatever
scp-340 3 was he seemed to be perceived
by each staff member as close in
appearance to their own race but that
was only the start of the anomalies
surrounding the old man in the holding
cell Dr Beck started making regular
visits to the mysterious man and in
their first interview he asked the old
man who he was and how he came by his
abilities the old man had a simple
response I created the universe Dr Beck
stifled the laugh and decided to indulge
the old man's solution it was a
fascinating claim but could he prove it
without another word
scp-343 got up from his chair laughed
and turned around and walked through the
solid wall in the holding cell and
disappeared Dr Beck was about to hit the
panic button and Marshal the facility's
security to find him when the strange
man reappeared walking through the solid
wall the only thing that was different
he was holding a hamburger which he sat
down and enjoyed the facility quickly
went on lockdown and a full
investigation was done into how s
scp-343 breach containment but there was
no evidence of any security breach no
failures in containment and no evidence
of any other cells failing scp-343
hadn't broken through the security he
had just ignored it as if it wasn't
there at all when questioned about how
he had gone on his hamburger run he
simply repeated his belief that he was
God in between bites of his fast food
treat this would be far from the only
time strange things happened around
scp-343 SCP Containment cells are as
secure as they need to be but even the
least strict containment isn't known for
its Decor which is why Dr Beck was in
for a surprise the next time he paid
visit to scp-343 the Bare Bones cell now
looked like a comfortable home decorated
in Old English Fashions the scientists
assumed that scp-343 had been making
many more trips out of his cell to get
accessories to feel more at home but
that didn't explain all the changes to
the cell no one could explain how he had
installed the Roaring fireplace in the
containment cell and everyone who
entered could swear this cell looked
many times bigger than any other cell in
the facility
scp-343 wasn't just breaking containment
he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility the rules of the
SCP Containment facility didn't seem to
be a concern to scp-343 but there was
one thing he didn't seem to want to do
Escape after every sudden exit he would
always return to his personal cell and
treat it as his home when interviewed by
staff members he was polite but vague
and everyone seemed to enjoy talking to
him it was decided to keep him on site
not attempt to increase his security but
restrict access and keep his room
guarded at all times to ensure only
researchers with level 3 access and
above were allowed to meet with him but
God works in mysterious ways minimal
Security Site 17 was one of the least
restrictive SCP Containment sites
hosting in anomalies that could be
safely contained and weren't likely to
mount violent escapes but as in every
SCP facility security was still taken
seriously and only those with proper
clearance could interact with the
subjects so why did scp-343 seem
impossible to guard while only level 3
clearance and above were allowed in the
guards assigned to protect the entrance
all seem to fall down on the job
security officer James who was supposed
to be keeping people out of scp-343's
cell had instead LED in multiple
visitors in addition to dropping in
several times himself when questioned on
why he had gone against orders and done
so he simply replied that 343 seemed
lonely and was so happy every time he
got company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do the security guard was
reassigned and new ones were brought in
but history repeated itself guards were
given stricter instructions to minimize
exposure but scp-343's presence always
seemed to influence them anyway his this
containment cell was a revolving door
with staff members at the facility
entering regularly for friendly
conversations Dr Beck decided it was
time to take matters into his own hands
he would meet with
scp-343-1-1 and express how dangerous
these security breaches were he would
try to convince the mysterious being
that he needed to stop influencing the
minds of the guards watching him or the
facility would have to look into new
measures to contain him Dr back entered
the containment cell and had a long
conversation with scp-343 and when he
emerged he had a big smile on his face
like he had just finished a reunion with
an old friend he gave the current guard
a friendly clap on the back and told him
not to worry so much about security
after all nothing bad was gonna happen
from letting people at the facility
visit scp-343 right he wasn't dangerous
in any way he also said that security
should bring him anything he requests so
he would feel less need to leave a cell
minimal security site 17 soon became a
model SCP facility with morale being the
highest of any site with most giving the
credit to the presence of scp-343
employees generally make daily visits to
his chamber and he seems to have an
encyclopedic knowledge of anything they
want to talk about including things he
should have no way of knowing guards no
longer quit their posts or break
protocol as their only real duty is to
keep track of who meets with scp-343 so
they can be interviewed and debriefed
after everyone's conversation is
different but they all report being in a
better mood after leaving than when they
came in no further information is
available on
scp-343's origins the full extent of his
powers or whether he is telling the
truth about being The God Who created
the universe the site director rubbed
his temples after hearing the
researcher's explanation so what you're
telling me is that we have an
uncontained highly powerful SCP that has
not only been breaking containment
whenever it wants but as managed to
destroy all the files regarding the
research on it the researcher's answer
was yes however the situation at site 17
seemed to be stable and they had come up
with a plan that should help to maximize
the positive effect
scp-343 has on the facility they were
even hypothesizing that staff from other
sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343's presence the site
director wasn't impressed though he
wanted the researcher to go back to the
drawing board and redo the research
after all if all the files were blank
how could they ever learn how to
properly contain it that's what the C
and SCP stood for after all containment
the researcher finally had to stand to
the director though and told them that
it wasn't a good idea that they had
already tried everything to contain
scp-343 but that it wasn't that he broke
containment it was as if he didn't even
acknowledge that an attempt had been
made to contain him he was omnipotent
aware of things he shouldn't and able to
do things that broke the laws of physics
without breaking a sweat there was no
evidence that this was God the creator
of the universe as he claimed to be but
there also wasn't any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn't the
researcher's best guess was that this
was a powerful reality vendor whose
abilities knew no limits and that the
only reason he was staying in the
facility was because he wanted to and
doing anything to change that might
cause him to change his benevolent ways
the director's side as much as he hated
to admit it his researcher was making
good points he wanted to meet scp-343
personally but did he need to know
anything first well sir the researcher
replied he likes hamburgers but beyond
that he'll take care of the rest he's
right there where we left him in his
home waiting for his next guest over 50
men and women clad in red robes kneel
before an Unholy altar they chant and
mutter indecipherable words words of
Cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
accountants this was before they fell
under the ungodly influence of a new
ruler the center of this makeshift place
of worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face while he's known to
the cultists as the tentacled god the
Beast they worship is known to the SCP
Foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their God all-powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother Marsh walks among their
crouched forms he whispers instructions
for the great day of Liberation that's
soon to come providing everyone plays
their part it's a plan months in the
making and one that if it goes off
without a hitch could free their
monstrous God into the world they would
strike at the very heart of their enemy
the SCP Foundation when they least
expect it and nothing shall stand in
their way how could they lose when they
have a God on their side but why did all
these normal people become violent
zealots for a squid-faced deity it all
began with a dream to those who
experience these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God hold Dominion overall at
first it just seemed like a strange
nightmare the ones who experienced it
woke up shaken in afraid hoping to shake
the images from their mind but they
couldn't every night the nightmare would
return they'd see the images the Red Sky
the dead and Enslaved the tentacled God
and after a while it would come to them
even when they weren't asleep eventually
happening whenever they closed their
eyes little by little this scene stopped
looking so hideous and started to look
glorious they felt this presence in
their minds slowly pushing them towards
their inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally had purpose they
were working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another they would meet in secret
exchanging information from the
prophecies their ruler sent to them in
their dreams they worshiped together
building altars and Idols to congregate
around they performed dark blood rituals
involving human and animal sacrifice it
was when brother Marsh the anointed one
arrived to guide them towards their true
mission that things kicked into high
gear just three months prior brother
Marsh had been an office drone working
in data entry for a large insurance
company before the tentacled god invaded
His Thoughts with a simple message free
me and the new world I create shall be
your playground since then he devoted
himself completely to the cause quitting
his job and maxing out his credit cards
to help fund his new life's purpose
infiltrating the SCP Foundation and
releasing his inhuman ruler from its
imprisonment that was the single goal he
United the cultist under freedom for the
tentacled God and at long last they had
all the pieces in place to strike they'd
finally gathered the necessary Intel to
subvert the will of the most powerful
secret organization on Earth even the
strongest institution is made of people
and people are weak unlike the almighty
tentacled God people could be broken the
people in question were Kelly Thompson
Sydney Levitt Jordan brosh Dr Juan
Gutierrez and Jillian Larson Dr Juan
Gutierrez was a researcher with level 3
clearance on the site where the
tentacled God was being contained Sydney
Levitt and Jordan brosh were both
security officers charged with verifying
Personnel clearance on site Kelly
Thompson was a member of site
Administration with research
authorization powers and Jillian Larson
was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr Gutierrez these
five were the key to getting access to
scp-2662 and bringing their plan to
fruition normally Personnel dossiers on
people working for the foundation were
highly confidential but the devotees of
the tentacled God had their ways they
had a number of computer experts in
their ranks more than capable of hacking
in and pulling some basic information
off of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turned to some good
old-fashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results of course while the cold
scrip on sanity may have been a little
tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
Task Force Town nine better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping Mall Cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these Foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother Marsh's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock tau9 had been charged with
tracking down any new SCP
p2662 Cults and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they need
to strike quickly and with overwhelming
Force the scp-2662 worshipers were able
to secure the addresses of the five key
Foundation personnel and station members
outside each of them including one who
could realistically imitate each they
waited for night to fall and broke into
each of their homes as they slept what
followed was a sequence of Ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of
freeing their God Dr Gutierrez was shot
in the head while he slept Sydney Levitt
and Jordan brosh were both stabbed to
death before either even realized what
was happening Thompson who'd gotten up
to use the bathroom went down in the
hail of machine gun fire Jillian Larson
had seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother Marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two-minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct Forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their Journeys to the site where the
tentacled God was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you worked for the
SCP Foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one
slipped neatly into position
disappearing into the familiarity of
office life but infiltrating the site
was one thing getting past the
belligerent bodyguards and into the cell
of the tentacled God would be another
thing entirely that's where the rest of
the cult would come into play heavily
armed with whatever Firearms they could
get their hands on the rest of the
devotees of the tentacled god brother
Marsh included would attack the
containment site head on
in the ensuing chaos the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site
could take advantage of the distraction
and break into the containment chamber
it was perfect they launched their
attack from the outside and
from within when brother Marsh declared
that the time was right the assault
began a legion of gun wielding cult is
seen to Spring out of nowhere and
started shooting up the warehouse that
was a front for the containment site the
site quickly mobilized guards and task
force members to take on the sudden
threat and just as brother Marsh had
anticipated the site director called on
the majority of town 9 to help repel the
violent cultists from their perimeter
townai obeyed leaving three task force
members behind a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their God what they didn't
expect was a group of five Foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two townai members
and taking the third as hostage while
the war was being waged outside the
infiltrators had found the tentacle
God's containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid War their hostage insisted that
you using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662 twice as tall as a regular man
with 10 huge tentacles emerging from its
back and their months of envisioning
this creature they pictured it sitting
on a throne made of thousands of human
bones ready to dictate its commands to
the obedient liberators what they
certainly didn't expect was to see the
tentacled god hunched over a computer
screen still God's work in mysterious
ways so they stuck to the plan and began
chanting they pulled out a sacrificial
dagger and began sacrificing their
captured tau9 member it was at this
point that
scp-2662 turned and saw what they were
doing with a look of pure horror he rose
up from his computer his headphones
getting caught as he did so he told them
to go away that he didn't want them here
and that them murdering people in his
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor in
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian God to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence Unfortunately they had to
deal with an attempted cult Invasion
every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent Cults who relentlessly
Tracked Down and Worship it with Arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining Town nine
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the SCP Foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept down a very strange anomaly sits in
a humanoid containment cell in the
minimum security weighing of site 17. he
walks talks and looks like a man but
everything else is convoluted in a
question mark this is scp-343 who like
his namesake God is likely to cause
arguments whenever he's brought up is he
the creator of all that exists the basis
for the abrahamic faiths or is he a
pretender a reality warper with immense
power and pre-dilection towards delusion
a courtesian of the House of maladrog
Matthew Methuselah Yahweh who knows
really it depends on who you ask and
which stories you choose to believe and
few people enjoy a good story more than
scp-343 himself if one day you take the
time to visit him in his room and ask
him to reveal a page in the long book of
his personal history he might be kind
enough to tell you a story a story like
this of an encounter with something
monstrous that few others could hope to
survive meeting face to face rewind a
few thousand years nobody knows how many
exactly God as he chooses to dub himself
walked across the cracked ground on
Warren sandals it'd been some time since
he'd seen an animal around here and even
longer since he'd seen a human being not
that this bothered him he'd never been
bothered by his own company on a long
walk like this of course he could have
sped up time or teleported but where was
the fun in that he was a tourist in the
world of sensation of experience of
Flesh bone dirt blood and Sand after all
where's the fun in creating a whole
universe if you can't drop in now and
then to visit and do as the Romans do
not that the Romans would be around for
another few thousand years even Atlas
must occasionally shift the weight of
the globe from his shoulders for a jaunt
around the cosmic neighborhood and
whatever passes for fresh air in the
vacuum God whistled the tune to himself
it was a craggy mountainous region he'd
found himself in the distant Peaks had
Frosted caps a breathtaking place where
many truly had their breaths taken away
how humans will so happily risk their
lives to do something extraordinary it
never ceased to amaze him he his stomach
rumbled oh how he enjoyed that sensation
one of the funny little quirks of this
human form that he weaved for himself it
was no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
Friendly Village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a general
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power God had always believed that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke Rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of The
Village's Town Square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some some terrible
battle had occurred here but something
was wrong no bodies not one from
defender or assailant How could a
thriving Village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and depraved
that it left even God puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on Earth he didn't have access to True
omniscience How could a mere human mind
Bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body in its skull and leave it dribbling
out of his nose and ears instead he
chose to walk around the ruins of the
village and investigate firsthand arrows
and broken Spears and swords littered
the ground some buildings were
demolished but there were no tracks or
stray projectiles that could suggest the
presence of Siege weapons now these
buildings look like they were were
ripped apart some even still had claw
marks what terrible Beast could have set
upon this town and done this then he
heard a voice quiet and pleading beneath
some nearby rubble a Survivor he rushed
over to the pile and evaporated it with
a thought underneath a feeble old man
covered in stone dust was quivering God
helped him up and guided him into one of
the few remaining Huts still standing in
the village they both took seats God
held up two hands cradling empty space
two cups suddenly occupied that space
both filled with warm healing tea he
passed the old man one of the cops while
sipping from his own he asked the old
man if he'd seen what had happened the
old man told him no he hadn't seen
anything in decades he'd been rendered
blind in his youth little did either of
them know that very blindness was the
only reason he was the sole survivor of
the massacre the blind man told God that
one of The Village's Scouts had gone up
into the mountain with a small Hunting
Party the group was gone for days until
one of the members the youngest among
them returned weeping frostbitten and
covered in blood he said that his
friends had been killed by a beast in
the mountains something that almost
looked like a man but terribly wrong and
its face it's awful awful face he would
never forget it he was just lucky to
escape with his life when the others
were torn apart but when the young man
returned he'd brought the shadow of
death with him it was a curse that
doomed the entire Village men women and
children to a terrible fate and that
fate was upon them a mere hour after the
Survivor had returned of course there
were gaps in The Blind Man's
understanding given he was lacking one
of his major senses but the sounds he
could describe with perfect clarity it
was faint and distant at first that
awful well and the Galloping hands and
feet thundering against the ground
faster than any horse could move getting
closer and closer another villager saw
it approaching and screamed then it was
upon them the villagers screamed but it
screamed louder always wailing and
shrieking and sobbing like a monster
crawling Straight Up From Hell people
tried to fight it by the sounds of it
the blind man with teary blank eyes
recalled the sounds of Eros knocking and
swords clashing against something but
even their greatest warriors had
screamed and died those who saw it and
tried to flee and hide were slaughtered
all the same soon enough there were only
two sounds left in the village the
monster and the blind man both weaving
he didn't understand why it never took
him it wasn't fair it took everything
else to leave him here alive when
everyone and everything he'd ever known
was destroyed was a greater punishment
than even death after killing all of
these Innocents the monster had simply
wandered off to the mountains again the
sound of its quiet sobs getting smaller
and smaller until it was gone altogether
God comforted the blind man as he wept
for the loss of all his loved ones he
told the blind man that he would venture
up to the mountains himself and confront
the creature on its own territory and at
the very least find out why it had done
this terrible thing but first he must
relocate the blind man to a safer place
he placed a hand on the Blind Man's
shoulder and he vanished he would appear
in another Friendly Village miles away
God sent a silent message into the minds
of every villager take good care of this
man he has undergone as you can to
even imagine your kindness will be
rewarded later for that you have my
promise God's side and turned his tired
eyes to the distant mountains a monster
lurked up there perhaps one of his own
Creations or maybe a Corruption of one
of his Creations either way whatever
existed without his knowledge existed
without his consent and he intended to
know of the beast in the mountains
though given what he'd seen already he
didn't expect to receive a warm welcome
from this murderous demon miles away up
in the mountains the creature licked the
blood from its cracked lips it looked
like it might have once been a human
being or something that aspired to
humanity or mocked it with its very
existence it was a huge gangling Beast
skin aliblaster eyes empty and soulless
dribbling rivulets of burning tears down
a hideous gaunt face he crawled into the
Frozen mouth of a cave with great icicle
fangs wheezing and weeping all it ever
wanted was to be alone why did they have
to keep interfering didn't they know
what happened all the terrible things
they made it do the creature curled its
long gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great ruts into the sides of
its bald Cranium with long sharp fingers
Terrible Things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised it turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with a kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes unwavering no no no no no
no no no no he could feel it again the
rage bubbling up deep down a cauldron of
seething anger it hated the feeling like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel it began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who I am
The Stranger asked with a deep voice
that betrayed almost infinite power
knowledge and wisdom but it wouldn't
change the outcome here the monster
bounded at him at speeds that wouldn't
be seen again until jet planes and
bullet trains are invented Millennia
into the future its jaws were hanging
impossibly wide fangs born its arms
extended and deadly claws ready to
strike but before those terrible hands
could close around the stranger he
vanished the monster stumbled and rolled
across the snow confused what trickery
was being used here I'll take that as a
no
said the voice from behind him you ought
to show your father some respect more
respect than you gave to those poor
people down in the village at least
seething the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness
of the cave staring at him but the Beast
didn't have the capacity for awe or holy
Terror only violence boundless Limitless
Unstoppable violence it darted towards
the stranger again trying to strike him
somehow it was like fighting an empty
robe not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the stranger the
stranger leaped backwards putting some
space between himself and the monster
but still not breaking a sweat he
breathed in deeply then exhaled the
breath came out like a mighty typhoon
shocking even the monster with its
sudden force it was blown backwards a
leaf in the wind until its Long Claws
dug into the ground and anchored it in
place the stranger gave a wry smile at
this impressed my mind or certainly a
tenacious one aren't you
he said perhaps we can talk for a little
while instead of fighting I want to know
why you killed all those people
no answer the Beast roared its Mighty
limbs pounding into the ground as it
closed the gap between itself and The
Stranger in fractions of a second it
would kill him rent him destroy him just
like all the others he'd left it no
choice suddenly the ground below it
seemed to give way the creature was
confused it looked down to see that the
ancient stone Below had somehow taken on
the properties of a liquid and it was
sinking the Beast panicked and it began
to thrash it was a strong swimmer but it
didn't expect to need to swim here the
shock was too much and soon the ground
submerged it entirely muffling its
terrible Roars and shrieks and just like
that the ground was solid again trapping
the Beast inside the stranger stepped
forward and looked at the ground a much
needed timeout
he said you do yourself no good
struggling like this despite its
terrible capacity for evil God couldn't
help but admire the beast at least on
the level of construction it was so
pared down so unburdened a killer to the
core but seemingly unkillable had he
made this creature billions of species
in the species those in turn had created
through billions of years of breeding
and evolution and somewhere along the
line this thing happened it was easy
even for the universe's Creator to lose
track of some of the tinier variables
and in the grand scheme of things even
this monster was still a tiny variable
but right here right now it was still
one hell of a problem the ground rumbled
below God cracks formed the mountain
peak shook God raised an eyebrow
genuinely impressed as the monster
ripped free of its Stone prison and
re-entered The Fray it roared and
screams still its blank eyes fixed on
him its skeletal body throbbed and
heaved with power unlike any other
creature in nature it was almost like
the longer their conflict went on the
more energized the Beast became God's
side all those poor villagers they never
stood a chance against this monster it
lunged for him even faster and stronger
than before he teleported out of the way
in the nick of time and the Beast claws
cleaved through a nearby cave wall
effortless God materialized nearby but
he didn't have time to speak the Beast
lunged again and again and again every
time he reappeared the Beast went for
him with impossible speed deciding to
widen the playing field God teleported
to the top of the mountain the creature
somehow sensing his presence vaulted
upwards and tunneled through the roof of
the cave bursting out of the ground in
front of God who was floating just
slightly off the ground it would be wise
of you to stop
God carefully entoned all this time you
know I've been going easy on you you
don't want to find out what the wrath of
God looks like
storm clouds were gathering above Mighty
Thunder roared across the sky the Beast
was undeterred it roared and galloped
towards God and God in turn called down
a response a volley of lightning the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or since struck down on the
charging monster the sudden white flash
could Sting the eyes from miles away the
monster shrieked from the blast feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and
atomized in the sheer heat of the
electricity around it it could smell
itself cooking the lightning blast only
lasted for a few seconds but for the
Beast it felt like eternity when the
onslaught stopped the air was still
heavy with electrical potential Gods
stared down at the black Scorch mark on
the side of the mountain where the
creature had been standing all the snow
within a mile had been evaporated by the
blast it was a raw display of the power
of nature that would make even Zeus
tremble in his sandals and yet there was
still movement some things started to
get up from the burnt patch where
nothing should be Left Alive a blackened
skeleton rising shakily from the ash but
still very much alive as it started to
Rise new flesh began growing over its
bones little by little even God was
astonished by the sight of it he'd never
seen a creature cling so ardently to
life in spite of having truly
unsurmountable power amassed against it
it was up against God and still it
fought the monster tottered on its
freakishly long limbs still disoriented
unusually staggered for a creature
driven by such single-minded violent
purpose when enough of its face grew
back to do so it began to weep and SOB
again tears streaking down its terrible
face looking at this creature after all
of this God couldn't help but feel a new
emotion pity he lowered himself to the
ground and approached the creature like
none had ever done before he gathered it
up into his arms and he held it feeling
its heaving wretched sobs against him
the Beast was in so much pain he could
feel it radiating from within speak
muscle God said in a soft fatherly voice
and for the first and only time the
monster spoke
[Applause]
look please
that was all it managed to choke out
before devolving back into
unintelligible Babble but it was enough
enough for God to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost Limitless
power to granted one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and God said
unto the Beast rest now child
rest for thousands of years
I hope only that when you eventually
awaken
and so another story from the catalog of
scp-343 of course it leaves us with
certain questions Chief among them being
is it true did 343 and 096 have this
chance encounter long ago or is this
just another tall tale from an anomaly
who fancies himself a deity we have our
truth and you have yours if you've ever
read the book of Genesis which is the
part of the Old Testament that details
God creating the world and Humanity
during a particularly busy week then you
might just be already familiar with
scp-001 or at least one of the anomalies
that's been proposed for the title of
scp-001 because of course
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation anomaly
sharing the name as cp001 include the
infamous Scarlet King a powerful
Eldritch being intent on ending all of
creation that is thought by Foundation
researchers to be one of the most
dangerous beings in this and any other
universe but the Scarlet King isn't the
only incredibly powerful being
categorized as
scp-001 in fact there are plenty of
other anomalies with similar levels of
destructive power and one such being is
a creature code named the gate Guardian
standing at well over a thousand feet
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these
scp-001 has historically been seen to
have any number of wings between 2 and
108 sprouting from various places over
its body including its shoulders ankles
wrists and even its temples this
gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as scp-001 1-2 this
weapon resembles an enormous knife or
sword capable of emitting plumes of
flame according to tests conducted by
the foundation the temperature of the
Flames produced by scp-001 rival that of
our very own Sun for reference the sun
has a core temperature of over 27
million degrees Fahrenheit and
5778 kelvin at its surface or almost 10
000 degrees Fahrenheit you would expect
a flaming sword that burns hotter than
the sun to cause a considerable amount
of damage even if it wasn't in use but
the Flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding
environment it is capable though of
annihilating anything that Strays too
close to
scp-001 burning them so intensely that
their atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate Guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
Gateway which is is equally tall as
scp-001 itself behind the guardian is a
lush Grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to scp-001 this Grove is thought to be
the Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own Garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of
scp-001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanosecond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at scp-001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to subatomically
vaporize both projectile itself as well
as the person who sent it regardless of
how far away they are all while not
appearing to lift a finger during an
experiment involving scp-001 on December
26 2004 an SCP Foundation nuclear
submarine called Nautilus launched a
series of multi-warhead intercontinental
ballistic missiles at the gate Guardian
the retaliation from the guardian
resulted not only in the depths of
approximately 35
000 innocent civilians but the blast is
also believed by some to have
inadvertently caused the 2004 Boxing Day
tsunami the severity of this incident
came dangerously close to revealing the
foundation's existence to the world
resulting in them rapidly deploying any
means necessary to erase any trace of
the 35 000 victims families friends and
other related individuals in order to
avoid questioning the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost
worldwide scale and the o5 council ban
and any further tests on scp-001 that
involved nuclear weapons in what was
hoped by the foundation to be a test
with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards
scp-001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thousand foot tall
entity with a flaming sword to tell them
twice the researchers running the
experiment were not swayed by the
request and ordered the d-class to
continue moving towards
scp-001 when the d-class continued to
ignore their commands they were
terminated as is standard policy when
dealing with an insubordinate member of
d-class
scp-001 appeared not to like this for
some reason though and the researchers
site as well as the researchers
themselves were immediately obliterated
by an unknown Force though it's a pretty
safe guess that a certain flaming weapon
was responsible this candidate for
scp-001 may be one of if not the most
powerful being that the SCP Foundation
has ever encountered and according to
its entry in the scp-001 file the
guardian is even responsible for the
creation of the foundation Nation itself
if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the SCP Foundation One
Day heard a word echoing through his
head prepare this one word instruction
led him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via a telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to scp-001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore These
Warnings though and scp-001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
scp-682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hard to destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt scp-682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment
scp-682 is also one of the few creatures
the foundation actively wants to
terminate a task made that much harder
given that 682 can regenerate its entire
form from as little as a single sell the
gate Guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of
massive destruction and researchers
working for the foundation hope to
harness that power to rid the world of
scp-682 for good 682 was placed on an
unmanned vehicle and carried to within
one kilometer of the gate Guardian the
guardian attacked the vehicle seriously
wounding but not killing 682 it seemed
even the mighty
scp-001 couldn't kill the hard to
destroy reptile while the researchers
were disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
Uriel but a pretender Uriel is the
Archangel that some religious texts
describe as the guardian standing at the
Gate of Eden with a fiery sword so does
this mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding is in
the Garden of Eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both scp-001 and
scp-073 the anomaly otherwise known as
Kane Kane is a male humanoid of possible
Arabic descent whose arms legs spine and
shoulders are replaced in almost
cyborg-like fashion with beryllium
bronze much like the gate Guardian
scp-073 may also be the same as the one
mentioned in the Bible's Book of Genesis
who according to the biblical story
murdered his own brother Abel out of
spite as punishment for his actions Kane
was cursed to eternally suffer for his
wrongdoing in the case of scp-073 any
damage inflicted on him is deflected
back to the attacker but Kane is made to
feel the pain of the attack any plants
or plant-based matter Withers and rots
in his presence and he is cursed with a
perfect memory keeping him forever
haunted by his murder of Abel when Kane
was brought before the gate Guardian an
unknown incident occurred the
foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
Kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on
scp-001 the encounter left scp-073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
o5 council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind work to be
conducted on
scp-001 with the administrator even
filing an executive order that no scps
be exposed to the guardian and that
scp-001 was to never be used for the
attempted termination of other scps of
course perhaps it wasn't just the
mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that scp-001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site-0 by
Foundation Personnel detailing an XK
Class end of the world scenario in the
trans transmission the sender believed
to be another member of the SCP
Foundation described an event during
which the gate Guardian finally left its
post stepping away from the entrance to
the Garden of Eden
scp-001 has left its location the sender
wrote the gate is open they are writing
forth oh God it's so beautiful the
transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the Lord shall
reign forever and hero Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
God deems a time his Angelic armies will
lay waste to the Earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
as cp001 the gate Guardian will open the
gate he stands in front of allowing the
other beings like it to emerge into our
world ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by Personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a timestamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate Guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to Eden waiting the
smell of fire and oil fills the air the
sound of Gear's grinding can be heard
between the explosions and shrieks of
Terror a man runs out of his house only
to have his leg grabbed by a metal arm
and dragged back through his front door
scp-001 leaves a trail of metal
fragments and mechanical Parts on the
ground in the wake of its destruction
iron Chain Swing from its form cast iron
gear swirl within it a glowing light
throbs from the center of its body
scp-001 is consuming everything in its
path after incorporating the truck
chassis into its being
scp-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion to
the next house it rips the gutters from
the side of the building residents who
live in the area flee their neighborhood
all the while hoping that the mechanical
monstrosity skips over their house so
they have something to return to if they
make it out alive a section of scp-001's
undercarriage drops away from the main
body it rolls down the street consuming
more and more material the new entity
resembles a human spine and rib cage it
topples over unable to support itself
the rib-like formations extend out to
grab anything and everything within
reach the newly Incorporated material
forms what can only be described as a
head light from within the eye sockets
fixate on nearby civilians the metallic
creature picks up the people in place
system inside its exposed steel rib cage
then it turns and spots a woman
helplessly trying to crawl away the
creature reaches out with a spiked
tentacle and wraps it around the woman's
body she is placed inside of the chest
cavity moments later a severed hand
falls out of the entity and onto the
ground the mechanical monster continues
to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half human half
machine humanoids turn and run away from
the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as
scp-001 the foundation had been in
contact with the Allied occult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worship the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near La Paz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the U.S border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside La Paz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La Machina the machine
the commanding officer order there's a
squad of foundation agents to proceed of
the tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards La Paz
disappearing Over the Horizon as the sun
sets the remaining Foundation agents
hear gunshots in the distance they stay
awake all night remaining Vigilant
waiting for the exploratory Squad but
morning comes without anyone returning
three days later the foundation Force
still has not seen anything since the
exploratory Squad left then as the sun
sits lazily in the morning Sky a lone
figure is spotted walking down the
tracks towards the trains one of the
agents on watch blows his whistle and
points to the figure a squad of Agents
rushes towards the shadow of a man their
guns are raised ready for anything the
figure drops to the ground and begins to
crawl along the tracks the agents reach
the Fallen man only to find that he is
one of their squad mates who has been
sent up the tracks to investigate La Paz
several days before the agent's name is
DeMarco he is covered in blood his
clothes are in tatters and he has lost a
boot DeMarco lies on his back with
Foundation agents standing around him
his eyes are wide and wild he keeps
babbling on about a world eater how the
rest of his Squad had been mulched and
he is the only one who made it out alive
the foundation agents carry DeMarco back
to the makeshift base they created by
the trains they need to figure out a way
to get the Convoy moving again but
whatever is up ahead has already taken
out an entire Foundation Squad it had to
be something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards La Paz
they start loading their rifles and
check the amount of ammunition and
explosives available in case the
containment process gets out of hand
just as they are about to leave the base
a convoy appears on the horizon it is an
Allied occult initiative Force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is
devastating La Paz this organization's
mission is to not secure contain or
protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the Joint Force with the Allied
occult initiative may be the only way to
stop what is now known as
scp-001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for La
Paz and what they find causes them to
Quake with fear
scp-001 has consumed so much material it
is the size of a mountain it moves like
a tidal wave of mechanical destruction
washing over the buildings and Landscape
under it whatever
scp-001 passes over is consumed and
added to its massive body
scp-001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal death machine the Church
of the broken God has finally met their
maker as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its
members their God is an all-consuming
monster the aoi and Foundation forces do
everything they can to stop scp-001 from
continuing its reign of Destruction they
fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical
anomaly they bring in air support to try
and damage it from the skies but nothing
works the aoi uses an artifact in their
possession to lure scp-001 to the coast
of the Pacific Ocean where a trap has
been set for the so-called God the
Monstrous mechanical creature moves
slowly towards the water it consumes
abandoned cars buildings and boats as it
approaches the coastline it even shovels
large amounts of Earth into its form
causing Flames to spurt out from its
inner workings smoke Bellows from
openings between different mechanical
components like a volcano before it is
about to erupt suddenly seemingly from
nowhere a massive cloud with a reddish
tint appears in the sky Air Raid Sirens
can be heard in the distance the
enormous Cloud begins to pulsate streaks
of lightning shoot through the Red Mist
in the sky it now sits directly over
scp-001 from within the cloud part of a
ship can be seen it appears to be
slightly damaged electricity flows over
its Hull the vessel in the giant Red
Cloud is classified as
scp-2399 the underside of the vessel
begins to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam
of light is ejected from
scp-2399 which penetrates straight down
and through as
cp001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if
scp-001 is trying to reach up and grab
the vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before scp-001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light
scp-2399 blinks out of existence the
sound of grinding gears can be heard
coming from within
scp-001 it begins to shed its outer
layers of metal then the entire
structure that was
scp-001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation Asian and
aoi agents approach the piles of scrap
metal and mechanical components they see
that some of them are still moving it is
as if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main wreckage of scp-001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized
scp-001 hundreds of anomalous artifacts
are collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of scp-001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Hearts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survived the collection ordeal with
their arms and legs still attached to
their bodies dive teams are sent into
the water to recover parts that have
sunk to the Bottom of the Sea one of the
divers is a local from the area he is
hired to bring up the heart of the
machine since he is an experienced diver
used to freediving to Great depths to
collect oysters from the bottom of the
bay the diver enters the water and swims
down into the murky depths he secures
straps around the heart of scp-001 and
pulls hard on the Rope as an indication
to the surface that it is ready to be
hauled up the Salvage team on the
surface begins to pull there is a second
slight tug on the road then it goes
slack the team continues to pull when
they get the heart to the surface they
are horrified at what else comes up with
it tangled in the ropes is the lifeless
body of the diver his head is smashed
between two moving pieces of the heart
it looks as if he shoved his head
between the slabs of metal himself the
Salvage team untangles the Body Rolls it
off the deck and back into the ocean the
mechanical box which was the heart of
scp-001 is offloaded on the shore but as
the foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of
scp-001 doesn't make it to the
foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new
religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains
corpses littered the facility around 20
in total their Massacre had unfolded in
a matter of seconds despite their
Advanced armor and heavy Weaponry their
killer wielding an ancient sword he'd
somehow pulled from thin air looked upon
them with disdain weak unworthy
opponents he breathed heavily his torso
was covered with bullet wounds and many
had punctured his lungs it was enough to
kill a normal Man 10 times over but not
him he was The Ultimate Warrior the
perfect killing machine he would need to
seek out an enemy more fitting for his
legendary combat skills he fled from the
chamber into a connecting hallway where
a giant metal door slammed shut behind
him at the other end of a hall another
door did the same he laughed at the
thought of someone thinking he could be
trapped so easily and charged towards it
but then large valves began to open all
around him torrents of freezing sea
water began pouring in filling up the
chamber and submerging him before he
could reach the door the warrior are
fought for breath and yelled at far
longer than any mortal man could
especially considering the state of his
lungs but water always wins he soon gave
his last gasp and floated lifeless in
the hallway and soon after his body
turned to dust and disappeared in the
Briny water but he would be back he'd
always be back his brother was a
different story tall and handsome with a
strange Sumerian Rune tattooed on his
forehead he was practically a pacifist
and spent most of his days reading
conversing with the staff and wandering
the facility of his own accord upon
hearing of the latest incident at the
facility he gave a sign he knew on some
level that all this was his fault it'd
been centuries Millennia even but was it
too late to make things right six days
later the two are standing face to face
this meeting had been a long time coming
but it was always destined to end in
Blood and pain the man with the runic
tattoo was on
the only thing he carried was his
regrets the warrior eyes full of burning
Fury drew his sword and not long after a
head hit the floor who are these two
strange men and what is the significance
of this fatal meeting in our own
Universe these two may never meet again
but that doesn't mean there isn't a
universe out there where they will and
it is that Universe where today's tale
Springs from the story between these two
began a long long time ago when they
were both set on a course of Destruction
but to learn how these two finally met
once again we only need to go back a few
days while they seem more human than a
lot of beings under the SCP foundation's
watchful eyes there's no doubt that
these two are anomalous they're known as
scp-073 and
scp-076 but better known as Kane and
Abel from the name alone most people
with a basic knowledge of the Bible
could tell that these two have a
connection but the particulars were
largely a mystery to the foundation they
wanted to know how much of the story was
actually true SCP researchers approached
scp-073 AKA Kane and asked if he'd be
interested in reuniting with his brother
one last time it took Kane three days to
answer yes but on one condition that he
was the only person who could abort the
mission the foundation mulled over this
requirement for three days before the o5
council finally made a decision
cross-testing approved these two
brothers separated by Millennia would
finally meet again and the SCP
Foundation would get to watch what
happened when they did of course for
safety reasons the cross test would take
place in 076's containment facility a
Bedrock chamber 200 meters Beneath the
Sea that would be the closest thing to
Safe this fateful meeting could ever be
though safe was really a relative term
when it came to
scp-076 his Escape attempts were as
frequent and unpredictable as they were
deadly and everyone who'd ever worked
with him knew exactly why to the
untrained eye would seem strange to
create such a complex facility for a
three meter squared Stone Cube known as
scp-076-01 but the cube isn't what's
being locked up here the real danger
comes from the corpse stored inside
known as
scp-076-02 but better known as able he's
a lean olive-skinned man who appears to
be in his late 20s but his most distinct
physical features the fact he's covered
in an elaborate network of Arcane and
occult tattoos largely of scowling
demonic faces similar to those found on
members of the Yakuza whenever Abel's
corpse reanimates as it does at random
intervals everyone in his vicinity is in
terrible danger he's capable of pulling
bladed weapons out of miniature
dimensional Rifts that appear around him
though he does this so quickly that it
seems as though the weapons are simply
materializing in his hands despite the
increasingly comp complex efforts to
contain him Abel has been able to breach
containment and go on Brutal Rampages
multiple times killing scores of
foundation Personnel in the process Abel
possesses superhuman strength speed and
durability during prior containment
breaches he was able to shrug off rounds
from 50 caliber machine guns these torn
through reinforced steel doors he's even
swatted bullets from both handguns and
assault rifles out of the air with a
length of Steel rebar only killing him
can truly end one of these Rampages and
the foundation has had to go to
terrifying lengths in order to achieve
this during past containment breaches
he's been drowned asphyxiated crushed
burned to death with a thermite grenade
directly inserted into his chest cavity
and even disintegrated by the activation
of the facility's on-site nuclear
warhead this may seem like Overkill but
if Abel were ever to make his way into a
major population Center the fatalities
would be well of biblical proportions
Eva even death can't keep him down for
long his body will rapidly decompose and
reappear intact with an
scp-076-01 there's no telling when he'll
reawaken in his periods of inactivity
can range from hours to years because of
this he must be constantly observed by
guards highly proficient in close combat
and always ready to go toe-to-toe with
perhaps the most dangerous melee
combatant in history he's such a
proficient killer that there was once a
project aimed at weaponizing Abel but
this turned out to be a disastrous
failure for the foundation when they ran
out of missions to give him Abel's
thirst for blood caused him to turn his
blade on his allies with no remorse
hacking them up with the same ruthless
abandon he gave his assigned enemies
interestingly Abel does seem to have a
twisted sense of Honor he has respect
for combatants capable of providing him
with a real Challenge and has even
expressed concern for guards he
considers to be respectable adversaries
but don't be fooled there is no
reasoning with Abel either you kill him
or he kills you and trust us he's much
better at it than you are while he's
Often overshadowed by world-ending
anomalies or more talkative Mass Killers
like scp-682 able is one of the most
deadly creatures known to the foundation
Abel's counterpart 073 is an entirely
different story despite his namesake
being the first biblical murderer this
cane is a far more enigmatic figure a
tall man in his early 30s appearing to
be of Middle Eastern descent he has two
very notable physical characteristics
the untranslated Sumerian symbol
tattooed on his forehead and the fact
that several of his body parts namely
his arms legs spinal cord and shoulder
blades have been replaced by mysterious
Prosthetics of Unknown Origin unlikeable
Kane is polite non-confrontational
articulate and communicative he's even
allowed to wander the facility he's
housed in Freely though with certain
regulations namely that Kane is never
permitted to come into contact with
plant life or uncovered ground this is
because in spite of the fact Kane
doesn't appear to Harbor any malicious
intent direct contact with him causes
plants to wither and die and the ground
to become infertile if Kane was ever
introduced into a natural environment
again he could unwittingly cause an
ecological catastrophe with his mere
presence in that sense he could almost
be as dangerous to large populations as
able however Kane's danger to Flora is
only one of his several anomalous
qualities another is extraordinary
mental capabilities and a near Perfect
Memory his memory and ability to recall
is so good that some Foundation
Personnel have suggested using Kane's
mind as a kind of backup server for the
foundation's collective knowledge but
perhaps his most well-known anomalous
trade is his ability to act as a kind of
a mortal human voodoo doll that's right
any damage inflicted on Cane causes no
permanent injury to him and is reflected
back on the the perpetrator while Kane
has remarked on still being able to feel
the pain of these assaults he's
functionally Immortal this damage
reflecting ability has even made
performing certain kinds of tests
impossible as doctors attempting to draw
blood from Kane have found that their
sample was actually their own blood and
their skin exhibited The Telltale
bruising and puncture marks of blood
testing but of most interest to the
foundation right now was the fact that
Kane has shown prior knowledge of Abel
however he was cagey when questioned he
refused to add any additional
information and commented that it would
be best if he and Abel were never
brought into contact but what does never
really mean when you live forever Kane
finally did agree to the test and while
nobody know what caused Kane's change of
heart the foundation knew better than to
push him and potentially get the entire
Mission scrapped Kane was taken from his
facility and transported to the access
point of Abel's underwater prison the
experiment's design was simple Kane
would occupy a temporary residence in
enables containment facility until he
next reanimated at which point the
interaction between them would be
closely observed perhaps it would take
weeks months or even years before Abel
once again awoke and left his Cube but
when he did Kane would be there
thankfully as Kane whispered soothing
words into Abel's tomb the resurrection
took only minutes if you were expecting
a heartwarming reunion think again Kane
tried to apologize but Abel immediately
struck him with a decapitating blow
which due to Kane's damage reflecting
properties caused him to suffer his own
head instead Kane remained at Abel's
side as he regenerated and as soon as
Abel did he immediately tried killing
Kane again it went on like this again
and again and again it was an arduous
process and eventually even Abel began
to Tire of it the duo fell into a
tearful Embrace Abel asked his brother
why he killed him so long ago and Kane
apologized saying it was the actions of
a younger and more foolish man in that
moment the two finally reconciled and
having fulfilled their bargain with
their creator both finally crumbled into
dust Peace at Last as we said this
didn't happen to the Canaan Abel of our
universe but when universes are more
numerous than grains of sand in an
endless desert such a thing has indeed
happened Somewhere Out There perhaps in
a Kinder Universe than our own we can
only hope that Cain and Abel May someday
get to meet and find the same resolution
but until then these brothers will
remain one of the most dangerous and
fascinating Duos in the foundations
catalog every time a bell rings an angel
gets its wings it's an iconic line from
It's a Wonderful Life and even if you
don't believe in angels it is a pleasant
image after all angels are the
embodiment of goodness and light so an
angel getting its wings has to be a good
thing right well as anyone who's ever
eaten one too many Christmas cookies can
tell you it's possible to have too much
of a good thing even something that
sounds like the embodiment of all things
good in theory can become deadly when
taken to the extreme that is where
scp-469 also known as the many winged
angel comes in this angel-like creature
is anything but innocent and in fact it
has been responsible for multiple deaths
of SCP Foundation Personnel during its
captivity
scp-469 may be deadly but it is also
undeniably beautiful in a mysterious
ethereal way when first seen it appears
to be nothing more than a massive pile
of pristine white feathers like
something out of a pillow commercial the
pile measures 24 feet in diameter and
weighs at least two tons however like
men any of the entities contained within
the walls of the foundation's countless
containment sites all is not as it seems
with 469. what looks at first glance to
be a pile of feathers is in fact a dense
curled mass of giant wings the wings
vary in size from the tiny wingspan of a
sparrow to the Staggering 3.6 meter
wingspan of the wandering Albatross the
one thing they have in common is their
plumage with each Wing being covered
with the same glossy white feathers the
foundation was able to perform a series
of x-rays on the mass of wings revealing
a skeletal structure beneath the
feathers like those of a bird the wings
bones are Hollow however they are
unnaturally soft and flexible allowing
for a range of motion that no known bird
possesses this accounts for the
curvature of the Wings and their ability
to coil tightly into each other the
X-ray also provided the first and only
recorded Glimpse at the creature hiding
underneath all the feathers at the
center of the layers upon layers of
wings is a humanoid creature curled into
a fetal position in defiance of the laws
of natural Anatomy every single wing
appears to be fused to this creature's
spine how would it be able to move under
the weight of these wings or even if it
could is as of yet unknown the First
Foundation Personnel lost to scp-469
were d-class personnel d-112 and d-624
who were sent in to investigate the
nature of the creature and attempt to
contact the humanoid entity identified
on the x-rays one one two and six two
four entered the room equipped with
gloves and protective eye gear as
scientists watched the situation unfold
on a monitor on a video feed No One
expected much to come with the encounter
the working hypothesis was the layers of
feathers would simply be too thick to
get through without seriously damaging
the bones it would be a fairly
uneventful experiment or so they thought
112 approach
scp-469 first and attempted to depart a
section of its feathers with his hands
as 624 stood back and observed the
moment his fingertips touched the
feathers a rustling sound filled the
room the feathers began to quiver
shaking as if all waking up at once from
a deep Slumber suddenly in the blink of
an eye the hundreds and hundreds of
wings unfurled and pulled one one two
into their depths he was swept into a
swirl of feathers and within seconds he
had disappeared from view completely
though 624 on the scientists watching on
their monitor could no longer see him
they could certainly hear him from the
moment the wings pulled him into the sea
of feathers 112 had begun to scream in
agony his screams persisted growing
louder and more desperate even as the
voice cracked and grew weak 624 stood
Frozen in place with fear and shock 624
was ordered to attempt to retrieve 112
from the feathers but made no move to do
so he simply stared shared at the
feathers eyes wide face pale as the pain
shrieks of his colleague bounced off the
sterile White Walls of the containment
room a guard called over the intercom
threatening to terminate 6-2-4 if he did
not attempt to remove 112 from
scp-469's grasp this warning seemed to
shock 624 back into action and he made a
run for the center feathers arms up to
protect his face again the sound of
rustling as the feathers began to Quake
the wings unfurled once more and 624 did
not even have a chance to turn back
before he was pulled in to meet the same
dismal fate as the other d-class his
screams of pain joined 112 as the
scientists watching over the monitor
could do nothing to help them as the two
men cried out in pain and horror from
within their winged prisons something
began to happen that the scientists had
never seen before the feathers started
to shake again faster than before and at
first the wings appeared to be unfolding
again upon second look though it was
clear they hadn't moved there were
simply more of them now as the men
continued to scream more feathers
appeared the wings stretching out and
elongating as new Wings sprouted as if
from nowhere
scp-469 appeared to be feeding on the
sound of their screams and using that
energy to expand it was only after
several long minutes when the screaming
finally stopped that the growth of the
Wings did too at this point the wings
shifted again expelling the bodies of
112 and 624 from within its folds
dropping them limply on the ground
though their deaths were unfortunate the
loss of 112 and 624 did reveal some new
information about
scp-469 first that it could grow and
apparently needed to feed on sounds in
order to do so second that it was deadly
to humans and most likely to other
living things as well autopsies of 112
and 62 Force corpses would later reveal
exactly what happened to them and how
SCP for 469 kills its prey the 469's
feathers may look as though they would
be soft to the touch each feather is
actually made up of sharp barbs that are
capable of piercing clothing and skin
these barbs release a neurotoxin into
the system that activates every pain
receptor in the body of the victim the
neurotoxin present in these feathers has
not been identified anywhere else in
nature but is somewhat similar in
structure and function to the
neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue ringed
octopus in addition to the pain-inducing
neurotoxin the feathers also carry
several unidentified stimulant compounds
where the neurotoxin on its own would
induce enough pain for the affected
party to pass out almost immediately the
stimulants serve to keep the victim
conscious SCP Foundation scientists
posit that this is so that 469 can get
as much noise in this case in the form
of Screams out of its pain as possible
and Achieve maximum growth before the
captive creature dies or goes into shock
further experiments confirmed this
Theory and showed that scp-469 will
react similarly when exposed to any
living creature capable of making a
sound and experiencing pain not just
humans non-living matter though
including dead animals elicit no
response from 469 additional experiments
were then undertaken that involved
applying various different sounds in
order to test their effect on
scp-469's growth though it feeds on any
sounds produced in its presence it seems
to respond most strongly to musical
sounds exhibiting a particularly strong
response to classical music no sound
elicits a stronger reaction from this
creature however than the sound of
ringing Bells it is rumored that when a
bell was wrong in the presence of 469
the humanoid at the center of the
feathers is said to have moved for the
first time on record apparently whatever
is at the center appeared to wake up and
unfurl its wings revealing itself but
unfortunately all secure 30 footage of
this incident has been White and the
data has been expunged from the record
leaving the creature's true form a
mystery you may be remembering that four
members of foundation Personnel on
record were lost to scp-469 and that
only two have been mentioned so far the
second pair of casualties resulted when
the foundation attempted to terminate
scp-469 believing that there was no more
scientific benefit to keeping it alive
or at least that the possible benefits
did not outweigh the risks it was
ordered that scp-469 be terminated by
any means necessary to Skilled Personnel
Dr Jones and Dr Smith were sent into the
containment facility in Hazmat gear
armed with several sharp instruments
they were to attempt to use these to cut
through the forest of feathers and soft
bones until they could reach the
humanoid at the center it was presumed
that once they did and the creature no
longer had the protection of its
poisonous feathers that it would be
relatively easy to kill they could not
have been been more wrong Dr Jones
approached the dense cover of feathers
with a pair of sharpened gardening
shears while Dr Smith opted for a
machete at first the strategy appeared
to be working Dr Jones made several
Quick Cuts with feathers fluttering to
the floor and sticking to the Hazmat
suit as Dr Smith slashed into the
feathers with his machete making
similarly promising progress however the
situation quickly took a turn for the
worse when Dr Jones dropped her shears
and let out a blood curdling screen the
feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin but
somehow they managed to find a way just
the same Smith grabbed Jones and
attempted to make a break for it but he
was too slow and far too close to the
feathers already the wings wrapped
around them and swallowed them both up
leaving the researchers outside helpless
to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet
after several minutes they finally did
and now larger
scp-469 had officially claimed named
another two Foundation Personnel
obviously 469 could not be terminated
using any methods that would place the
responsible Personnel within its grasp
that was simply too risky so the
foundation selected a team of d-class
personnel to attempt to burn the
feathers with an array of flamethrowers
though the feathers were vulnerable to
Fire and began to Blacken and
disintegrate on contact the sound of the
Flames being expelled was loud enough to
feed
scp-469 its growth was so quick in
response to the noise that the fire
could not keep up with the amount of new
feathers and wings being produced by the
same time the flamethrowers ran out of
propellant 469 was the same size it had
been when they started other
terminations have been discussed
including the possibility of submerging
the entire creature in a highly
corrosive acid but so far this has not
yet been attempted whatever they end up
trying it is clear that nothing that
produces a significant amount of noise
will be able to kill 469. so where is it
now what's become of this perverse angel
with the never-ending Wings currently it
is kept in an airtight soundproof
chamber where nothing can trigger the
growth of any more wings so what is it
an angel a demon a twisted mutated bird
of some kind it is entirely possible
that we will never know but it's a
wonderful life had something right even
by accident every time a bell rings
something twisted and deadly though it
may be gets its wings man it's even
better on the 15th read oh hello I
didn't see you there dear viewers of SCP
explained I'm on break between
supervising a CPU 682 termination
attempts and inspecting the mops we use
on scp-173's leavings so I decided to do
what all the cool people are doing in
their spare time right now rereading
chainsaw man the hit manga by Japanese
author and artist tatsuki Fujimoto for
the uninitiated it's the story of denji
a poor young man from Japan who makes
his living hunting Devils dangerous
creatures that are embodiments of
Mankind's greatest fears but when that
living leads to him dying at the hands
of a gang of zombie Yakuza believe me it
makes sense in context he bonds with the
legendary chainsaw devil and is reborn
as chainsaw man an unconventional
superhero who chainsaws first and asks
questions later naturally I was eager to
see how one of our own bloodthirsty
Killers would fare against denji's
chainsaws of Fury so I selected the most
violent battle-hardened and Carnage
hungry anomaly out there
scp-076-2 The Immortal Warrior known as
Abel the two of them have a surprising
amount of things in common both are
effectively Immortal and can revive
after sustaining massive physical
injuries both absolutely love to fight
with their array of deadly weapons and
anomalous strength both have been part
of experimental operations groups with
denji being a member of Japan's Public
Safety devil Hunters division IV and
Abel being an ex-member of the SCP
foundation's disastrous Pandora's Box
mobile task force most of which he later
massacred out of boredom you can
probably see why these two really did
feel like the perfect match-up so after
forcing the trusty animatron 6000 to
read every currently available volume of
Chainsaw man and compute years of Abel's
gruesome battle data I've set up the
perfect simulation for your viewing
pleasure and hey fellow fans of the
manga isn't it horrifying that a even we
beat mappa to the punch of animating
this thing
oh God that joke will age poorly if that
anime comes up before this anyway let's
crank this machine into action and let
her rep Japan
1997. everything is roasting in the July
heat Men In Black Harrison Ford's Air
Force One and Air Bud are hitting
theaters for the first time ever
everything is right with the world
that's why over in the headquarters of
the public safety devil hunting
Department denji our chainsaw loving
hero is being praised by his kind boss
and Mentor figure makima a lovable
supportive woman who will never do
anything wrong she even loves dogs how
could a person who loves dogs ever be
evil that very morning denji and his
chainsaw man form managed to defeat the
accidentally making a mistake on your
tax forms and now you're going to prison
devil who had been terrorizing downtown
Tokyo it was a challenging battle but in
the end he'd managed to turn the tables
and defeat the creature by setting it on
fire needless to say makima was
extremely pleased with dengie's work
here but now she had considerably more
Graver news to impart she'd gotten word
from an Envoy of another organization
that hunts down dangerous and anomalous
creatures the SCP Foundation that an
extremely lethal entity had breached
their containment and was now somewhere
in Japan the entertain question was not
a devil and thereby would be working on
a different rule set makima opened a
file fax to her by the foundation yes
remember this is set in 1997 and gave
denji The crucial Lowdown several hours
ago the entity known as Abel had
resurrected from his huge black
sarcophagus in the underwater chamber of
the classified facility containment area
25b after waking up Abel had slaughtered
his way through the entire base killing
every SCP Foundation operative in his
path and then swimming out into the
Pacific Ocean sometime after that he
infiltrated a Japanese cargo ship and
murdered all the workers on board before
steering the ship back towards the Land
of the Rising Sun where he hoped to
claim even more victims makima told
denji that it would fall to him and his
associates to stop this able With a
Little Help from the SCP foundation's
intelligence but being warned warned
Abel is an incredible combatant with
extreme physical strength and durability
as well as surprising technical
intelligence it wouldn't be an easy
fight but makima promised that if denji
won she'd hug him and go to a nearby
karaoke bar with him Dungy replied
consider him dead already miss makima
meanwhile Abel was walking through the
slums of Tokyo marveling at the neon
signs for bars and clubs his journey to
Japan hadn't been an accident Abel had
been to Japan once before in the year
1605. he'd face the legendary Japanese
philosopher and swordsman miado Musashi
considered by many to be one of the
greatest warriors in human history Abel
had dueled Musashi who famously wielded
two katanas at once in the hills of the
harima province where after a tense
battle Musashi cut him down Abel would
not resurrect again during Musashi's
lifetime but the battle gave him a deep
and abiding respect for the legendary
Abel knew that if the opportunity ever
rose again he would return to Japan in
hopes of experiencing such a brilliant
battle yet again but the industrial and
technological boom had changed so much
it was no longer the quiet and pastoral
Japan he'd experienced but a booming
epicenter of trade and commerce he
founded all strange and perplexing
suddenly he found himself surrounded by
a group of Japanese street thugs many of
them wielding switchblades they laughed
at his strange outfit which to them
looked like an old worn bed sheet one of
the smarter members of the group had
already decided to go home when the
others made up their mind to mug able
the Warriors extensive tattoos made him
look like a middle eastern Yakuza Dawn
the rest however were happy to take
their chances with him emptier pockets
of that goofy toga even has pockets the
leader said holding up his switchblade
unless you want to get cut Abel just
smirked and Drew a pair of long obsidian
daggers in the following Moment The
Alley was filled with screams then was
silent yet again Abel walked on
breathing a sigh of disappointment at
how incredibly mediocre this first fight
had been his blade stripping with fresh
blood Musashi is rolling in his grave
Abel thought to himself meanwhile across
town denji and the rest of division four
were mobilizing it was him the serious
swordwheeling Aki and the adorable
pathologically lying blood-phiend power
they'd been told over the phone by a man
named Dr bright that Abel would be
relatively easy to track down he's not
known for his subtlety all you need to
do is follow the trail of Carnage he
causes wherever he goes from the way he
talks about him it seems almost as
though Dr bright Bears a personal grudge
against Abel how strange power didn't
seem intimidated she proudly proclaimed
I don't think this battle will be
difficult at all in fact I faced this
Abel before and if he him handily Aki's
side and asked when did this happen last
Tuesday of course
she replied power had only heard about
Abel this morning but denji and Aki had
learned better than to dispute her at
this point suddenly a large television
screen that had been previously relaying
an ad for a cutting-edge stereo system
cut to an emergency news report there
had been a horrific incident in downtown
Tokyo where a bar had been attacked and
most of its patrons murdered by a
deranged tattooed man carrying a pair of
huge swords Aki immediately recognized
this place the bar was Yakuza owned if
this able was on the hunt for worthy
opponents it makes all the sense in the
world that Japan's iconic crime
syndicates would be his first Target
denji Aki and power knew exactly where
they needed to go over at the bar Abel
was having a whale of a Time innocent
patrons were running and screaming while
the Yakuza engaged in an all-out war
with a terrifying inhuman Warrior
several of them had already been cut
down two Yakuza soldiers behind the bar
were reloading illegal Uzis and
preparing to return fire both were
sweating terrified by the sudden random
attack when they'd shot him before he'd
managed to dodge most of the bullets and
expertly block the rest with his swords
who the hell had sent this monster was
he with the Triads the Russian mob or
some devil summoned by the Japanese
government to crack down on them
whatever the case he seemed almost
impossible to kill the two men stood
back up and opened fire Abel held his
two swords and spun like a propeller
blocking all the bullets almost
effortlessly he then produced another
dagger seemingly from thin air and threw
it directly into the heart of one of the
two remaining Yakuza behind the bar he
dropped to the ground dead instantly
leaving only his friend alive in a bar
full of corpses that's when Abel noticed
a decorative katana behind the bar he
smiled and ordered the surviving Yakuza
Soldier to pick up the sword and give
him a real fight the hapless monster
realized in that moment that this this
guy was truly crazy whoever he was but
what choice did he have now with tear in
his heart the last surviving Yakuza
grabbed the katana and uncheathed it
good Abel said his voice deep and
menacing now come fight me let's see if
you last a few seconds longer than your
worthless friends shall we he did not
the second the Yakuza ran towards Abel
and the ancient swordsman swiped at him
with one of his blades cutting through
the katana and the opponent holding it a
puny gangster never stood a chance
against a deadly Immortal Warrior and
Abel was Furious the last time he was
here he faced a truly expert killer who
even managed to end Abel's life in a
single combat and now he was slaying
insects in a karaoke bar pathetic
suddenly his ears pricked up he turned
to see a red ax flying at his head at
incredible speeds with his superhuman
reflexes he managed to dodge just in
time but the ax don't cleaved off a
chunk of his hair as it passed Abel
could see the one who threw it standing
at the entrance to the bar it was the
blood fiend power that made the ax out
of her own blood standing next to her
were denji and Aki denji wielding an ax
and Aki stoically observing damn Miss
makima promised we do karaoke at this
bar if I beat you Dungy said you're
going down for this Abel smiled and
pulled out another pair of blades
finally he roared Warriors who fight the
old-fashioned way I feared the years had
stolen you all from me power step
forward producing another Blood Ax from
nowhere she yelled tremble in fear Abel
tis I your arch nemesis
Mighty Mouse hour Abel had literally
never seen her before and is thousands
of years of life but he appreciated that
these warriors were at least able to
match his level of drama as far as he
was concerned the fight was on but even
Abel didn't know the level of fighting
he was getting in for here as he charged
forward the trio split immediately
surrounding him good tactics Abel
thought to himself already this was
promising Aki who had remained quiet up
to this point attacked first he drew a
tatano knife from his suit jacket and
slashed at Abel with impressive speed
but unlike three of the other combatants
in this situation Aki was only human
which gave him a serious disadvantage
Abel decided it would be best to put him
out of commission first with a quick and
brutal kick to the chest Aki was thrown
against the wall with the majority of
his ribs broken revved up by his own
bloodlust Abel turned to dengian power
and grin like a maniac this was already
the most fun he'd had in a long time who
are these people doesn't matter he
thought they'll be soon anyway while
Abel was still locked in thought power
pulled out a comically large Hammer made
out of her own blood and brought it down
towards Abel he was surprised by the
sudden attack did this girl have the
same weapon producing Powers as him this
just keeps getting more interesting this
is the end table power screen does the
hammer came down you have once again
been defeated by the mighty power again
just to clarify these two had never met
each other but it was already too late
Abel punched upwards his clenched fist
colliding with the hammer he had it with
such terrifying force that powers blood
Hammer shattered against his knuckles in
that same instant Abel noticed Genji
running at him with an ax from behind
Abel produced another obsidian dagger
and threw it into denji's forehead
dropping him to the ground immediately
pathetic power tried to produce another
weapon but she used up too much blood
already before she had a chance to make
anything substantial Abel sprung
forwards with terrifying speed trying to
land a killing blow but even weakened
power was freakishly fast she was able
to dodge his blow and kick him in the
ribs momentarily stunning him of course
she took the time to gloat putting her
hands on her hips and laughing
victoriously
need a second to catch your breath
he grandulously announced perhaps you
should just give up and agree to become
my servant
I might even teach you a thing or two
about fighting suddenly bull was
standing right in front of her squeezing
her throat with his iron grip he smiled
flashing teeth and said if you want to
kill kill don't talk with a surprisingly
minimal amount of strength he squeezed
and heard a crunch from power's neck he
dropped her limp body to the ground
lucky for power Abel wasn't aware that a
fiend-like power can survive an injury
like this as long as she's fed some more
blood instead he just sighed in
disappointment is that all you weaklings
have to offer he bellowed Aki barely
conscious after being kicked against the
wall remain just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a Powerful
Beast known as the fox devil he twists
his hands into a strange gesture and
Whispers the word Kong before falling
unconscious but that's still enough
suddenly a gigantic demonic Fox claw
burst through the wall of the bar
spraying dust and Rubble everywhere Abel
was definitely not expecting that he
dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him often barely missing him for its
last Strike It lunged Forward and raked
four claw marks across his chest Abel
was shocked by the sudden pain it felt
fantastic he pulled a long obsidian
spear out of one of his pocket
dimensions and forced it down through
the fox Devil's paw and into the ground
pinning it in place after a moment of
thrashing the claw dissipated into smoke
lending Abel another Victory though even
he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been was
that it had he gained total Victory once
more just like he so often did these
days he was about to take pity on
himself when denji rose up behind him
how about a rematch then she asked Abel
grinned he liked this kid challenged me
child Abel said well since you asked
denji smirked denji reached into his
shirt and grabbed the rip cord emerging
from his chest it was time to go into
overdrive on this thing he gave it a
mighty yank and like the Rev of a
chainsaw the madness began denji
transformed giant blades emerging from
his arms and his head transformed into a
toothy saw blade nightmare he gave a
mechanical Roar that spewed smoke this
wasn't just Dungey anymore this was
chainsaw man now this Abel thought
feeling his adrenaline spike is more
like it following dungey's lead Abel
reached into one of his pocket
dimensions and pulled out one of his
favorite weapons one he'd only
previously used against the mighty hard
to destroy reptile
scp-682 the chainsaw Claymore a huge
two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting shredding teeth of a chainsaw
ever circulating around it it was time
for chainsaw vs chainsaw what the hell
are you waiting for chainsaw man Roar
are we gonna stand around all day or are
we gonna fight Abel couldn't have said
it better himself the two charged at one
another at lightning speeds chainsaw
clashing against chain sword the sheer
force of the contact was enough to send
a shock wave blasting through the bar it
rapidly became a power struggle each of
them trying hard to force their
chainsaws out of the stalemate realizing
that this time he perhaps couldn't win
with raw strength able back flipped away
to reassess his options but chainsaw man
had no intention of giving Abel time to
think about it he darted towards Abel
with the weight and momentum of a
runaway freight train if able hadn't
raised his Claymore to Perry it would
have been shredded to Pieces by the
devil's saws in an instant instead the
two of them rocketed out of the nearby
wall in a Cascade of debris causing
everyone on the outside Street to run
for their lives the two quickly stood
from the stumble the two quickly stood
up catching their breath impressive Abel
said you're much better than the others
instead of replying denji briefly
retracted his arm chainsaws and grabbed
a nearby parked car throwing it directly
at Abel Abel reacted quickly leaving the
car in half with his Claymore and
charging for chainsaw man again just
before Abel could land a lethal strike
chainsaw man deployed his chainsaws
again blocking the blow Abel sped around
him trying to strike again and again but
chainsaw man blocked every strike with
stunning efficacy Abel was astonished
few had ever been able to go Toe to Toe
with him like this before he could feel
his heart pounding gloriously in his
chest he would give denji A Warrior's
death for the Furious yell Abel brought
down the chainsaw Claymore for a
devastating vertical strike but chainsaw
man was ready he arranged his arm
chainsaws in a cross formation like a
giant pair of scissors and caught Abel's
chain sword between them chainsaw man
pulled his arms in opposite directions
slicing Abel's mighty sword in half the
immortal swordsman skidded backwards to
avoid the Fallout producing two smaller
blades immediately this chainsaw man
just kept exceeding expectations didn't
he Abel would need to change tactics if
he wanted to win this one chainsaw man
was impressed by the speed and tenacity
of his Foe for someone who apparently
wasn't even a devil Abel sure packed a
hell of a punch did he ever run out of
those damned weapons though attempting
to answer chainsaw man's question for
him Abel began running around his flank
rapidly producing and throwing blades
and axes in a startling volley chainsaw
man was able to use his chainsaw arms
and face to block most of them but not
all of them several daggers and small
throwing axes splattered into the tender
flesh of Chainsaw Man's Chest Abel had
successfully wounded him and he wasn't
done feeling a little more confident now
Abel decided to take a different tactic
he produced a large spiked mace from
thin air and ran at chainsaw man while
the devil was still recovering from his
projectile attack with one brutal whack
he sent denji flying down the street
carving a rut into the concrete beneath
him but Abel wasn't done while chainsaw
man was still trying to recover Abel
leaped on to him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace the
strikes were so brutal they shook the
Earth and sent cracks across the
surrounding ground then Abel stopped he
realized for a moment that he was
letting his bloodlust get the better of
him this was dishonorable where would be
the fun in beating this boy to death
while he lay on the ground and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents
he's had in quite some time no that
would not do it all he'd give him one
more chance on your feet boy Abel said
you fight well get up and carry on I
won't let a beast as rare as you die
like a common dog rise and fight me and
Chainsaw man did as he was told Abel was
shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as chainsaw man burst up
through it all his swords at the ready
the mace was thrown from Abel's hands as
chainsaw man launched up towards him all
metal teeth and fury luckily for Abel he
pulled out a battle ax just in time to
block the flurry of brutal strikes from
the patron saint of chainsaws now this
was a fight even Musa she would be proud
of yes Boy Yes Abel yelled this is true
combat chainsaw man replied with the
swing of his blades which Abel was
nearly able to dodge the two finally
landed back down on the ground and Abel
was fast enough to bury his battle ax
and Chainsaw man's shoulder before the
devil could return a blow to Abel the
anomalous swordsman pulled out a pair of
his favorite swords and locked chainsaw
man's arms in place chainsaw man was
undeniably incredibly powerful but it
looked like Abel's Superior experience
and tactics might save him this time
what the hell are you chainsaw landlord
you've been a worthy opponent boy those
are feeling fine between Abel said I'll
remember you for this but before Abel
could execute a killing blow he felt a
blood red throwing ax stick into his
back Abel winced in pain to see Power
and Aki about 30 feet behind him power
was propping Aki up he donated some of
his blood to bring her back to life and
she was just as delusionally cocky as
ever Abel was about to say something but
he already made a fatal mistake letting
his guard down before another word could
pass the cursed Warrior's lips one of
Chainsaw man's armed chainsaws passed
directly through his heart tearing it
apart with enable's chest it was a
sudden and decisive killing blow
chainsaw man pulled his saw back out of
Abel's chest stained with the deadly
anomaly's blood Abel collapsed to the
ground wheezing and bleeding profusely
from the hole in his chest but strangely
as power Aki and Chainsaw man converged
around him they realized he was smiling
thank you Abel said and died yet again
with the battle won like an Incredible
Hulk made of metal chainsaw man
transformed back into denji the trio
stood around Abel's corpse deeply
confused as to what had just happened if
this was the kind of thing the SCP
Foundation normally dealt with they all
silently agree that perhaps it would be
better not to get involved with them
future except power of course who said
you two should be thanking me for
defeating him
you both owe me drinks for this hundreds
of miles away in a black sarcophagus
deep underwater surrounded by
professional SCP Foundation divers
Abel's body once again returned who
knows how long he'd remained sleeping in
there but what we do know is that his
deathless sleep was suffused with the
sweet dreams knowing that this world
still held or the opponents and for Abel
that was everything we'd been so
cautious keeping quiet only moving at
night but sometimes despite all your
best efforts you just get unlucky we
made our way through what we thought was
an abandoned Street littered with broken
down cars from those things had
slithered out and ambushed us kaspar who
was always the most trigger-happy of us
panicked and opened fire with his
scavenged submachine gun on the largest
of the creatures big
they didn't slow the monster down and
only seemed to attract more it'd be Blob
City Before Sunrise now but poor kaspar
wouldn't make it that long fleshy
tendrils wrapped around his Limbs and
pulled him into the terrible mass of one
of the creatures it started reshaping
around him enveloping him as he screamed
until the tide of Flesh coursing down
his throat silenced him the whole time
the monster just kept jibbering Madness
in a warped voice become one yes let
ourselves spawn and our minds coagulate
in the Glorious shimmering light we will
all be one in daylight pretty flower yes
yes yes
and then there were four me Ellen Darcy
and Jones there have been more of us
once but in this war of attrition we
always seem to be the ones who had to
lose and if we didn't get away from
these monsters quickly then there
wouldn't be any of us left soon enough
we ran ducking and weaving around the
cars as the blobs got closer there were
so many of them all howling and ranting
zealots for the only cause their melted
excuses for Minds could understand
anymore occasionally we fired back
hoping to slow them down a little but it
never worked The Guns of anything were a
psychological support mechanism and
something to scare off other survivors
who were even more desperate than us
when it came to the blobs especially the
big ones the only things you could do
were run and hope and hopes in short
supply these days no matter how fast we
ran the blobs kept catching up they
didn't seem to get tired knowing we
couldn't outrun them we ran up to one of
the abandoned cars and Crouch behind
them breathing raggedly this whole
stupid mission in hopes of eventually
reaching safety the good night's sleep
behind solid walls and some people who
actually know what the hell is going on
I drew my sidearm out of my pocket even
if I didn't make it out of here I wanted
turn into one of those monsters pulling
back the hammer I muttered a quiet
prayer but there's a God out there he
had a hell of a lot to answer for right
now I looked at Ellen Darcy and Jones
and they all had the same idea it was a
pleasure to know them all after
everything that had happened we heard
the blobs getting closer their lunatic
Whispers growing in volume and intensity
as they always did before they claimed
one of us I breathed in a sigh ready to
accept my fate knowing what I needed to
do it all seemed to be over until he
appeared I looked up and spotted a
strange man approaching he was dressed
in an old-fashioned Hessian toga his
hair and beard Frosty white I couldn't
identify his age or race but those
factors seemed secondary to the fact his
eyes were glowing brilliant white as if
exuding Pure Energy he raised a hand the
same glowing Aura of Pure White Energy
emanating off of it I'd seen so many
things that terrified me in the past six
months but this this was the first time
I'd experienced something I could call
all he walked towards us with a
Stillness and confidence and said you
look like you could use a hat where were
you when day broke whoever's left they
remember I was in a supermarket with my
wife and two kids just another normal
day I was worrying about bills taxes and
whatever we were going to have for
dinner that night if the devil exists
I'd sell my soul to that nasty red creep
to get those worries back lucky for us
we're in the back half of the store but
entirely by artificial light the people
checking out their groceries down front
right in the front of the building's
huge glass facade they were the first to
go down all these terrible drowned
screams first the exact kind of shrieks
you'd expect from somebody starting to
melt than the gurgling like a backed up
drain as their mouth and throat melted
around the sound choking it those were
the first few minutes of hell on Earth
I've never been the smartest man I was a
roofer back when things made sense never
to college never been much for reading
but I had intuition and I credit that
with surviving this long my dad was in
the service two tours and um he always
told me when I was a kid the guys who
didn't make it back they panicked
because that's what the enemy wants you
to do they hope when everything hits the
fan you'll break formation forget the
plan and I'll start scurrying in
different directions like rats just
hoping you'll be the one who finds a
crack and gets out that's when they get
you when you panic you're giving up the
birthright of reason and letting the
animal take over an animal's son are
easier to kill when the sun went bad
that day plenty of people in that store
started running they didn't know what
they were running from or where they
were running to they just wanted to put
some distance between themselves and the
screaming every man for himself I'd love
to tell you all those people are dead
now but in actuality they were in for a
far worse fate they ran out of the
safety and cover of the store putting
themselves at the mercy of the light
even as they melted they kept running
they were blobs slithering away not even
knowing that the thing they were running
from had already gotten them it all
happened so fast but I can remember
every single detail you can judge me if
you like I don't care anymore if I could
have spoken reason to those terrified
people that day hand on my heart I would
have but one of man's greatest design
flaws is that God made fear the master
of Reason nothing I could have said that
day would have changed anything the only
ones I could hope to save were my family
so that's exactly what I did we grabbed
what we could stayed away from Windows
made our way to the nearest Supply
Closet we are in there for hours we
didn't come out until things were
actually quiet which coincidentally
happened to be night when we stepped
outside the store we saw the Carnage
that must have unfolded over the past
few hours Windows smashed cars driven
into storefronts and abandoned
slithering blobs of former people on the
ground in the space of a few hours the
world had truly and irrevocably changed
no matter what what happened even if we
survived we knew there would never be a
normal as we'd know it before ever again
the same message was playing on every TV
radio and computer a logo I didn't quite
recognize along with an overlay that
read an important message from the SCP
Foundation it explained in an eternally
looping robotic voice that they were
superseding the control of all World
governments to protect Humanity from
this new and terrifying threat in short
the sun had turned against us in some
scenarios survival is a curse in those
early days and weeks you wouldn't
believe the number of times I started to
Envy the dead people who'd been wiped
off the Mortal coil by disease and car
crashes and random acts of violence in
the days before day broke they had no
idea how good they had it little by
little in this terrible New World thus
became a kind of luxury because melting
under the fiery gaze of the Sun that
wasn't death not even close they seemed
harmless at first tragic pitiful really
the voices on the TV even told us that
to avoid starvation we could eat small
parts of the melted but over time the
situation evolved I don't know when it
started or why but the blobs that had
once been people started coagulating
they joined up started turning into
bigger creatures all with one mind
always screaming and talking Madness in
a collage of stolen voices these
monsters existed for one purpose and one
purpose only finding the people who were
still normal and dragging them out into
the light to join them they roamed the
world during the night hunting seeking
and given night was the only time we
could ever safely move this created
problems for all of us we lost so many
to those terrible monsters including my
wife and both my kids see what I mean
about survival sometimes being a curse
especially when you've got people to
miss I wish they were dead all three of
them but I still hear them their voices
added to the chorus of a house-sized
flesh monster but I lived on if you can
call this living I met with others like
kaspar Ellen Darcy and Jones all of them
had lost people you hadn't lived this
long if you hadn't lost people we did
all we could to keep surviving against
the odds we spent we spent our days in
basements and abandoned stores and our
nights dodging the flesh creatures and
foraging for food we eked out each day
taking every breath as it came we didn't
hope for anything until one day we heard
that the people at the SCP Foundation
might know how to reverse all this they
needed all the people and help they
could get at one of their bases around
20 miles from us it'd only be a couple
nights walk to get there we figured so
why not help out the cause safety and
numbers after all and truth be told we
miss people after days of hiding and
nights of traveling we were ambushed but
you already know about that part we lost
kaspar to one of those monsters and got
cornered behind an abandoned car however
as the blobs got closer and closer that
mysterious stranger with the glowing
eyes appeared he didn't walk like the
rest of us he was bold confident his
back straight as a dancers like he
feared nothing like nothing here could
hurt him suddenly I felt a rumbling
behind me the car was rattling I feared
for a second that the blobs were
crawling over it to get us but when I
turned I saw the opposite was happening
the car was Rising off of the ground
free-floating myself and the other
survivors stared in astonishment as the
stranger simply flicked his wrist the
floating car was thrown with tremendous
Force at the largest of the advancing
blobs it hit the Beast so hard that the
top of it simply splattered off freezing
what was left in place even the other
blobs paused seemingly astonished we all
turned to the stranger Still Standing
firm stand behind me if you wish to live
said there was something both passionate
and commanding about his voice it was
impossible to hear him and not heed his
words all of us stood up and ran behind
the stranger as he lifted both hands
debris climbed into the air cars rocks
broken glass the blobs were beginning to
coagulate again but this time the
stranger wasn't going to let them get
the upper hand again with a slight nod
everything he'd raised flew at the blobs
with the force of a machine gun they
were decimated the bigger ones cut apart
the smaller one fleeing to avoid the
onslaught after months of running from
these monsters I don't think any sight
could have been more satisfying when the
creatures were gone the stranger just
gave a quiet sigh he turned to us and
asked if we were okay the answer was
essentially about as much as we can be
he told us that we'd be safe as long as
we stuck with him and after that display
we had every reason we had every reason
to believe him we followed the stranger
Down The Long Dark Road he always walked
in the middle Fearless making no attempt
to hide when we asked him his name he
told us that he goes by many names but
for the sake of Simplicity we could call
him Matthew we thanked Matthew for
saving us and he gave a sad sort of
smile and told us that he only wished he
could have done more there was something
so strange about Matthew even beyond the
fact he apparently had superpowers had
never met the man before and I'd be
willing to bet my right hand on that and
yet it felt like I'd known him my entire
life he was so different from yet so
incredibly familiar we told them we were
on our way to a nearby SCP Foundation
facility where we were told we'd find
Safe Haven we asked him if he knew where
to find it Matthew told us that in fact
he'd lived there in that very sight for
decades a visitor just dropping in he'd
had a very stressful job before and felt
like taking a sabbatical while things
ran themselves for once evidently my
help was more necessary than I imagined
he said occasionally as we walked we'd
see blobs watching us from crevices and
dark alleys on the side of the road they
seemed to watch but for some reason
didn't approach it was the most
remarkable thing don't worry he told us
I'm putting up invisible Shields none of
them can approach us as long as I
maintain my focus
of course we'd all heard stories of
remarkable and terrifying things
wandering the Wasteland we used to call
Planet Earth you couldn't run into other
survivors and groups without hearing
whispers about the things lurking out
there some had told of a giant monstrous
reptile that had destroyed an entire
Survivor settlement in a mall outside of
Nevada others told that one of those SCP
sites was haunted people spoke about a
ghostly man who looked like a rotten
corpse who could walk through walls and
drag people to hell but the things
Matthew was capable of seemed to be on a
whole other level I asked him what he
was and he told me just the humble
Craftsman myself I enjoyed creating
though admittedly my creation seemed to
have gotten away from me these days his
evasion was less funny than he seemed to
think it was I pressed on asking him
what exactly he was capable of he
Shrugged and answered that he could do
almost anything if he really put his
mind to it I asked so ultimate power
just gave him a chuckle
he shook his head and said let me tell
you a story The Man Comes upon a maze
cut into a cornfield and decides he
wants to dry his luck he spends hours
getting to the center of the Maze and
there he finds the devil waiting for him
the devil says welcome to my domain your
soul is now forfeit unless you can
complete my Challenge and win it back of
course the men agreed the devil said I
can see everything do everything and be
everything I know every inch of the
universe and can produce anything from
thin air if you want to keep your soul
name one thing I can do curious I asked
what did the man say Matthew smiled and
said get lost
and for the first time in those long
dark months I actually laughed and it
was such a stupid corny dad joke it's a
strange world we live in boy news
Matthew continued there is no ultimate
power some things are denied even to God
especially when he chooses to walk as a
man on the earth he created him we kept
walking for hours Matthew assured us
that we would get there in time as the
rest of us got even more anxious about
the thought of the Rising Sun he said
he'd seen so many sunrises now that he
could time them to the second in the
meantime we should enjoy getting to
stretch our legs a little even now the
city could be beautiful at night when he
led us all the way to what seemed like
an abandoned chemical plant I could feel
my heart sink all this time all this
work to find more people to find safety
only to see that this place was
abandoned too Matthew smiled and said
that's just what they want you to think
he snapped his fingers and the ground
around us began to rumble the concrete
shifted seamlessly and an entrance
opened up alone heavy bulkheads shifted
revealing a Sleek Chrome hallway down
into the ground we were astonished
Matthew gestured down into the Hall as
we descended Matthew followed us the
entrance closing behind him I'm just
warning you
said this may come as a bit of a shock
we venture deeper passing through
different automated security checkpoints
as cameras gaze down from above
eventually we found ourselves in what
seemed to be a central chamber it was a
hive of activity people in normal
civilian clothes guards and tactical
gear scientists and lab coats tears
filled my eyes it was the most people
I'd seen in one place a month a man in
the lab coat wearing an extravagant
Medallion approached he was making notes
on a clipboard another Badge of
survivors good work 343 the man said
Matthew smiled and nodded no problem
Jeff always happy to help
The Man With The Medallion Jack
presumably turned to me I imagine you've
come a long way he said I nodded
you have no idea reality warpers real
pieces of work aren't they it's one
thing when an anomaly is all Claws and
fangs like scp-682 or if their attack of
choice is snapping necks like SCP-173
but it is an entirely different story if
an anomaly can turn the air you breathe
into chocolate pudding or shove you into
a pocket Dimension that looks almost
like our own reality except everyone is
just a walking talking pile of spiders
see what I mean reality warpers real
handfuls though of course not all
reality warpers are created equal some
are relatively weak only affecting the
world around them in a mild ambient
fashion others can rattle whole
Dimensions with their tremendous power
the same also goes for Morality some
reality warpers are loving and
benevolent such as scp-343 the kindly
old all-powerful being known to some as
God and some are pure evil beings who
want nothing more than to use their
immense power to sow chaos and misery
among everyone else and personally we
can't think of a better example of the
latter than Bill Cipher from Gravity
Falls this demonic Dorito wants nothing
more than to take over our Dimension and
rebuild it in His image of absolute
Insanity so naturally we started
wondering if these two reality warping
Titans scp-343 and Bill Cipher ever came
to blows who would win we were so
curious in fact that we fired up the
animatron 6000 our state-of-the-art
simulation supercomputer to see how
exactly the two might meet and how their
epic battle would play out who do you
think would take the coveted W on this
one let us know down in the comments
along with any other out of universe
what-if situations you'd love to see but
in the meantime let's fire up the
machine be warned folks it's gonna get
weird the date was July 12 2013. for SCP
343 it had started out as a relatively
normal day he'd spent the night playing
Solitaire on the astral plane before
warping back into his humanoid
containment cell by morning leaving the
foundation on the wiser after all he was
really here voluntarily if the
foundation had truly wanted to try to
confine him here they were welcome to
give it a go but it would be about as
effective as trying to catch a whisper
in a butterfly net while God had come to
this place to experience the joyful
illusion of giving up control it truly
was little more than an allusion to him
if he wanted to he could exterminate the
SCP Foundation in less than an afternoon
then retire to Burger King for a Whopper
so really they're all just lucky he is a
benevolent being more interested in
hanging out than dispensing wrath on
those he perceived as insolent that was
Old Testament him he'd done a lot of
soul-searching and growth since then
they'd been at least a millennium since
he'd smote anyone for that matter and
the last guy really have it coming
however today was going to be a little
different God knew that something was
going to happen today he sensed a great
source of energy emerging something dark
and malevolent he sighed and he closed
his eyes for a moment focusing himself
he knew whatever the nature of this
threat it would fall upon him to face
and destroy it how irritating he was
hoping to finally binge stranger things
today elsewhere inside 19 things seemed
to be inordinately peaceful there hadn't
been any containment breaches or new
anomalies brought in there hadn't been
any attacks from rival groups of
Interest Dr Wright hadn't even done
anything stupid or started any fires to
borrow an old cliche it was quiet too
quiet perhaps the only person who wasn't
having a relatively mellow day was
security officer Frederick Simmons a
mid-level guard who'd been stationed at
site 19 for four years now he just
wasn't really feeling himself today the
work didn't bother Simmons emotionally
at least typically even after seeing
rather traumatic things or being in
near-death situations while in
containment breaches it hadn't left any
lingering effects but lately he'd been
having the strangest streams it always
played out the same way shortly after
going to sleep he'd open his eyes in a
strange multicolored void surrounded by
bizarre seemingly random floating
objects none of which seemed to have any
real relevance to him or his life and
just when he'd begin to question it the
other recurring element of the dream
would occur out of the shimmering oil
slick rainbow of mind-boggling colors a
strange being would suddenly emerge a
glowing Golden Triangle almost like a
drawing of a pyramid the Eye of
Providence with a stove pipe hat a
little bow tie thin black arms and legs
and most notable of all a single large
eye with a slit pupil staring out from
the center the eye almost seemed to have
a string range hypnotic quality to it
Simmons felt Bewitched whenever he
looked into it he wasn't afraid quite
the opposite actually for reasons he
couldn't understand this strange
creature from the world of Dreams seemed
like a good friend of his he said well
well well well well if it isn't my
number one guy the Fred Meister in the
house I've missed you have you missed me
put her there good buddy The Entity
extended his hand and Simmons shook it
the foundation guard could feel a
strange tingling sensation jolting down
his arm the first time Simmons had
encountered The Entity he'd told him his
name Bill Cipher and he told him how
incredibly important it was that Simmons
kept their little nighttime meetings a
secret in Exchange bill was here to
listen Simmons would spend his time in
the mindscape pouring out his worries
and frustrations with his daily work as
bill paid impeccable attention the
strange Little Dream entities seemed
fascinated by the work Sim instead all
the peculiar and wondrous anomalies he
guarded at site 19. but to Simmons it
was all just boring work zombie creating
Supernatural plague doctors and Immortal
men with metal limbs lose their shine
after you see them day in day out for
years on end frankly Simmons needed a
day off but he'd already used up all his
PTO when he'd gotten the flu earlier
that year he just didn't know what to do
luckily for him Bill had a solution bill
as it turned out had a fancy little
ability he could occupy the body of a
human being and operate it for them bill
could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape how hard
could standing around pretending to look
busy at the SCP Foundation really be as
Bill explained the offer to him Simmons
couldn't really see any flaws in his
reasoning after all bill was a friend
why would he have any ill will towards
him with that he shook hands with the
bizarre Supernatural triangle and felt
the sudden rough sensation of having his
Consciousness ripped from his body only
for Bill to Slither in and take his
place the new Simmons the bill occupied
Simmons opened up his demonic yellow
eyes and grinned he gave a demented
laugh to Simmons floated disembodied
soul
[Laughter]
oh man he said wiping away a tear of
laughter with Simmons finger with your
body I
Kea sucker and with one last demented
chuckle Bill left for work at the SCP
Foundation with Simmons being the latest
in his long line of Meat Puppets after
arriving at site 19 he sneaked through
the facility knowing exactly where he
needed to be you see Bill is a native
entity of the second dimension the world
of flat shapes but he's able to access
the minds of beings in the third
dimension like us through the medium of
the mindscape rather than the Physical
Realm Bill's life goal has always been
to find a way to permeate and take over
the third dimension turning it into his
personal playground all he needed was
the right anomaly to bring him forth
into our world in this case a little
anomalous device favored by Dr Kane
pathos Crow
scp-158 also known as the soul extractor
while Dr Crow Left To the courtyard for
his evening walkies the being that most
people assumed was Fred Simmons secreted
himself into a scp-158's containment
chamber and locked the door behind him
he didn't have much time he'd need to do
this perfectly if he wanted a real
chance at taking over the universe he
was amused by the irony at the
leap the fact that in order to take over
he needed to sneak into the midst of the
people most likely to destroy him still
where's the fun in life with no risk at
scp-158's control console he inputted
the data to Soul extraction and set a
timer however there was one difference
between this and the usual procedures
performed with the soul extractor there
was no containment receptacle on the
other end whatever was extracted would
just be released into the world and this
was exactly what bill was counting on he
laid Simmons body down on the gurney and
watched with Glee as the robotic arm
lowered towards him it reached into his
chest and pulled out the essence of one
three-sided threat to reality Bill
Cipher one quick Journey Through the
bowels of the machine later the
nightmare scenario had come to pass Bill
floated around the room dragged into
physical reality he let out a long
conceited cackle and spun his Cane
around this was is going to be fun
elsewhere in the facility alarms were
going off and guards were deploying
nobody was meant to be in containment
chamber 158 so how was the sole
extractor currently operating this
couldn't possibly end well bill on the
other end was having a wonderful time it
was pondering all the different ways he
could make the drab clinical corridors
of the SCP Foundation into his vision of
perfect weirdness maybe he turned all
the researchers into mice and turned
site 19 into a giant maze to run them
through maybe he turned the air into
farts and release winged beasts from the
hell Dimension to ravage Humanity maybe
he'd go out into the parking lot and key
everyone's cars oh the Diabolical
possibilities were endless as he floated
out into the Hall his fantasizing was
interrupted by a group of foundation
security operatives wielding assault
rifles they entered an attack formation
and trained their rifles on him before
opening fire bill just found himself
laughing again the gunfire just tickled
wow you guys are hilarious Bill said
between fits of laughter but wait I
could think of a better way to make you
even funnier he snapped his fingers and
suddenly the guards were transformed
instead of the serious first line of
defense for the SCP Foundation they were
now a gang of literal clowns straight
from the circus holding balloon animals
molded into the shapes of assault rifles
they giggled and threw pies at each
other bill was right this did make them
even funnier and he was just getting
started turning this Foundation snooze
Fest into a party of cosmic proportions
Bill began running a rampage of
weirdness across the site essentially
being the ultimate Cosmic troll he
decided he'd simply bother every single
anomaly he could with his demonic Antics
first he appeared in scp-096's chamber
and pulled a brown paper bag over his
head with the words ugliness lies within
written on the front and just for fun he
then teleported the temperamental Beast
to a nearby Amish community it quickly
became enraged when a gust of wind blew
the bag off its head and a man named
Jebediah saw its face it then killed
several others also named Jebediah
during the Rampage Bill thought it was
hilarious he then released scp-682 into
site 19 and just to annoy the creature
into further violence he stuck in
indestructible party hat on the
monster's head no matter how hard 682
tried it couldn't remove the party hat
this caused it great frustration which
it took out on any foundation staff it
happened to find in the area it had
fulfilled Bill's expectations
wonderfully but his quest for amusing
Carnage didn't end there next he went to
bother scp-049 the plague doctor who was
in the process of doing surgery on a
foundation-provided dead goat with a
snap of his fingers Bill transformed the
plague doctor's surgical tools into
colorful Play-Doh cutting tools needless
to say the supernatural surgeon was less
than pleased he was about as annoyed as
Dr clef was when bill turned his
favorite shotgun into a bouquet of
flowers then sealed his feet into the
floor or how Vex Dr gears was when bill
turned his plain beige necktie into a
considerably more loud and colorful tie
people there at the time reported
hearing Dr gear say I just don't think
that was necessary oh and he also did
some more minor acts of malice he filled
the break room with an army of
flesh-eating zombies he made a mode
filled with molten lava around the site
that prevented anyone from escaping from
his reign of terror and he even covered
all the walls in cognito hazardous
Doodles that instantly drove any
weak-minded human who saw them into
complete gibbering Madness it was clear
this reality warping nightmare needed to
be stopped before he got bored of
playing with his new Foundation toys and
decided to go remodel the universe in
his own image thankfully there was one
anomaly on sight who was up to the task
bill was treating himself to another
evil laugh in the site-19 canteen when
something peculiar happened he looked
down to see a man in what looked like a
tuna with grain hair and a beard he
walked with a peculiar kind of calmness
his face blank why wasn't the sky
panicking was he stupid bill would
seemingly need to teach this guy a thing
or two about fear hey grants don't know
if it's escaped your attention but I've
been giving this place an Extreme
Makeover did you forget to put on your
glasses this morning or are you just
that senile The Stranger remained calm
as could be it replied with a voice that
was measured as it was deep now Bill
let's not resort to name calling that's
just childish don't you think Bill's
single eye widened at this wait wait
hold up how did you know my name Bill
asked irritated are you a friend of the
time baby or something he floated over
and began circling the stranger hoping
to intimidate him much to Bill's
frustration it didn't appear to be
working I know lots of things Bill lots
of things The Stranger replied that's my
line Bill screeched turning red who Do
You Think You Are The Stranger gave a
quiet Reserve chuckle that infuriated
Bill oh personally I just like to think
of myself as a humble Craftsman watching
his beautiful creation play out he said
but I suppose some of the people around
here like to call me God
Bill didn't like this this whole
universe was going to be his and he
certainly didn't appreciate some insulin
old man acting like he ran the roost
around here bill would give him an
education in who was really holding the
Reigns and it would be the kind of
education that left scars if it left
anything at all he extended his spindly
black arms and released bolts of
lightning against the stranger who
simply continued to smile as the
electricity rippled around him seemingly
causing no effect are you done the
stranger asked Bill laughed hoping to
hide his irritation I'm just getting
started he bellowed with a thunderous
Roar that shook the very foundations of
sight 19. Bill began to grow and shift
no longer a silly little triangle he
became a huge Red Pyramid of pure
nightmares covered in glowing Golden
Arms and teeth with long black tongues
drooping out of each level it was the
most terrifying and demonic form in his
entire Arsenal and yet he was astonished
to find that the stranger still didn't
seem to show any kind of fear very
impressive Bill The Stranger said
sounding almost bored but I think you
might be trying a little too hard oh
that does it bill would simply have to
destroy him it was a matter of Pride now
he raised several of his huge golden
fists and began pounding down on the
comparatively tiny humanoid stranger it
was an assault so powerful that the
ground began cracking around their feet
and yet it seemed that with almost no
effort The Stranger was able to
intercept and block every single blow
naturally bill was infuriated it was
time to finally unleash the full breadth
of his power on this beardy wise guy he
launched Thunderbolts Fireballs Legions
of giant mutant wasps hail storms
maelstroms bubbles of pure Madness
snakes made out of barbed wire and even
incredible coarse language but despite
it all this man the one who claimed
called him God was utterly unfazed you
can dish it out he said but let's see if
you can take it Bill began to laugh what
the heck's that supposed to mean you
can't God snapped his fingers and Bill
was gone vanished and with a flick of
his wrist all the damage and
Transformations that Bill had performed
had disappeared it was as though the
Demonic triangle had never even been
there in the first place though Dr
bright who was acting site director at
the time had some Scranton reality
anchors turned on around the perimeter
just to be safe you can never be too
careful with reality warping demons
after all later that day Dr bright
approached God and asked him what he'd
actually done with Bill God chuckle then
replied for a being of such a man's
power he really had a rather childish
mindset so I zealed him away inside a
children's cartoon where he couldn't do
any further damage what was the cartoon
Dr bright asked a Charming little Disney
show called Gravity Falls God replied
addiction it takes many forms and wears
many faces like a demon walking Among Us
it takes over your life crawling in and
changing you from the inside out
breaking an addiction is hard but
oftentimes not giving it up is much
harder that was a difficult lesson to
learn for three people Joey Walker Dolly
McGregor and Paul Ables these three had
never met one another and now they never
will but each one of them had two things
in common first was that each had an
addiction they felt like they couldn't
shake and second was that they each had
a run-in with
scp-66 Joey Walker was at the end of his
rope when he encountered it everyone has
bad days but for Joey every day for the
last 15 years has been a bad day it was
pushing 40 with nothing to show for it
except credit card debt a scraggly beard
and a beat up old Mustang but booze had
always been there for him no matter how
bad things got he could always count on
a glass full of comfort at the end of
the day but to paraphrase a quote by
Stephen King sometimes when a man takes
a drink the drink takes the man and Joey
Walker had been long since taken he was
a transient worker doing jobs wherever
jobs needed doing but he never expected
that he would end up all the way to
Tibet working construction not that he
was complaining but sure it was cold but
there was plenty of Tibetan Chang to
enjoy it was a drink so good that
Legends even say that yetis would raid
villages in the mountains just to get a
little taste Joey had taken a liking to
the Chang and it was what he had been
drinking when he crashed his car up in
the mountains leaving him stranded in
the snow Joey had survived the crash
itself but he knew he wouldn't last long
in the cold he needed shelter that's why
he felt like he could hardly believe his
luck when he first saw the the yurt a
kind of traditional Tibetan tent made
from animal skins Joey had never seen
anything quite like it but any Refuge
from the storm would do he pushed
forward through the snow and climbed
inside but the inside of the yurt was
nothing like the outside in fact it
seemed like an exact replica of his
favorite sports bar back in Atlantic
City it was warm there was all the old
memorabilia on the walls and every
screen was showing the Saints wiping the
floor with the Colts in the 2010 Super
Bowl Joey didn't even question it he
just smiled and approached the bar he
even recognized the bartender Malcolm a
good old friend of his Malcolm smiled
back at him but there was something
oddly menacing in his grin welcome back
he said I thought you'd hauled your
sorry keister off to the bed guess you
gave up on that too just like everything
else
well except Malcolm pushed a glass of
beer towards him across the bar and
glared Joey didn't understand why
Malcolm was being so aggressive but he
didn't question that either he grabbed
the glass and drank it up guzzling it
down before slamming The Empty Glass
down on the bar Malcolm kept the drinks
coming round after round and Joey kept
knocking them back he didn't notice when
the TV screens turned to static he
didn't notice when the other patrons at
the bar began to Jitter and twitch
turning little by little into something
less than human he didn't even notice
when Malcolm's face started melting off
his skull as long as he kept pouring
before he could even really understand
what was happening to him Joey Walker
was dead his liver and kidneys had given
out on him his corpse would later be
found Frozen on the Tibetan Mountainside
just 30 feet away from his crash car the
coroner's report would list his cause of
death as accidental but this was no
accident he'd Fallen victim to
scp-66 an anomalous yurd known to some
as the spirit house the being he'd call
Malcolm is known to the foundation as
scp-66-1 and Joey had failed its
challenge sadly for our inebriated
friend the penalty for failure is death
next on our list of human tragedies
comes Dolly McGregor a 62 year old woman
from Anaheim California dolly was never
averse to the drink but she knew how to
enjoy her Mojitos in moderation you
rarely get to 62 if you don't and Dolly
could tell people with pride that she
had two children and six grandchildren
whom she didn't see nearly often enough
for her liking she also had over one
hundred thousand dollars in gambling
debt owed to a number of casinos on the
Vegas Strip ever since her husband
Albert had passed away several years
prior shooting craps playing Blackjack
and willing away the hours in front of
the slot machines had been a welcome
change from
but in Vegas fortunes can change in an
instant Dolly had gone from being on a
hot winning streak to losing everything
the casinos extended her lines of credit
until she was gambling with money she'd
never be able to pay back but that
didn't stop her she'd been selling off
everything even remortgaging the house
that Albert had built with his own two
hands to try and keep up with her
ballooning deaths still it wasn't enough
but she couldn't stop either it wasn't
even that she felt good about it anymore
it was just that she only ever felt
normal among the flashing lights of slot
machines and the clatter of dice she
needed to get away as far away as
possible she heard about people reaching
spiritual enlightenment in Tibet they'd
discover God or gods or sometimes just a
sense of inner peace whatever it was she
needed to find it and get this demon off
her back so she took the last of her
savings and flew off to Tibet to clear
her head she didn't know if there were
any casinos in lhasa but if there were
her money would surely be no good there
it was exactly what she needed but Tibet
wasn't the promised land she thought it
would be wherever Dolly went there she
was with the same vices and demons
chasing her the first night she spent in
lhasa she used the hotel Wi-Fi to
download an online poker app on her
phone this culminated in another couple
thousand dollars lost and a panic attack
that caused Dolly to throw her phone
into her toilet before wandering off
into the Wilderness she just needed to
get away but time and space got away
from her and eventually she was
knee-deep in snow where had she come
from where could she go it quickly
dawned on her that if she didn't find
some kind of shelter soon she'd be done
for but all she could do was keep
walking that's when she happened upon
scp-66 the yurt was like an oasis on the
baron Mountainside she didn't expect
Comfort inside but it could at least
provide her some shelter until the Staff
back at the hotel noticed she was gone
then they'd come and save her right
right but when she passed through the
yak leather flap into the yurt Dolly
wasn't in an ancient tent in the Tibetan
Wilderness she was on a casino floor
there was a big beautiful roulette table
before her attended to by a grinning
well-dressed coupier they were flanked
by an army of slot machines and all the
pleasing familiar sounds of cheerful
gambling rang out through the air she
approached the table and the croupier
shook his head in what seemed like
disappointment ah back again a dolly he
said with a sigh of course I should have
expected it after all what else do you
have in that empty little life of yours
without all this you'd be nothing right
nothing at all since Albert died and the
kids want nothing to do with you we're
all you've got so Dolly what'll be red
or black are you feeling lucky his words
wound to Dolly but that wouldn't stop
her she grabbed her chips and put them
all on red one last spin couldn't hurt
what did she have to lose she blinked
and she wasn't sitting at the table
anymore she was upright but she wasn't
standing her wrists and ankles were
bound to something to a wheel a giant
roulette wheel like it was some kind of
medieval torture device the crippier was
standing across from her while something
that used to be a croupier his face was
flickering in and out sometimes it was
humans sometimes it was a mass of eyes
and teeth more demons were sitting all
at the slot machines behind him pulling
levers made from human bones good choice
Dolly the groupier said red suits you he
reached out and gave the wheel a spin
dolly was lost in an overwhelming
pulsing Cascade of Lights colors and
sounds the horrific tinny noises of slot
machines and the laughter of the Demonic
group here she was lost in panic and
Terror as she just kept spinning and
spinning and spinning when her body was
eventually found her muscles were in the
advanced stages of atrophy as though she
hadn't been moving for years her brain
was rotted and the cause of death was
determined as sudden cardiac arrest
after an extended period of sleep
deprivation and malnutrition Dali's
family would never really know what
happened to her the SCP Foundation has
learned a lot about scp-66 after
containing it in site-73 its anomalous
effects namely Vivid complex and
potentially fatal hallucinatory
experiences only affect those with some
kind of addiction or dependency to
anyone else entering the yurt it's just
a normal tent but any addicts who enter
will fall under its spell and are
generally transported back to the place
where their addiction was at its
strongest there they'll encounter
scp-66-1 an entity that takes the form
of a figure from the subject's life
normally one heavily involved in
facilitating their addiction any kind of
addiction seems to trigger it alcohol
drugs gambling pornography Foods
self-destructive Behavior even video
games
scp-66 kills its victims with a twisted
mockery of the very thing that they were
dependent on in life it was only with
Paul Ables that the foundation started
discovering the other side of the coin
by almost all accounts Paul is a worse
person than anyone on this list he got
addicted to hard drugs early on in life
and took up a life of violent crime to
support his habit he murdered two people
during a liquor store robbery before
being convicted and sentenced to death
he'd then been picked up as a d-class by
the SCP Foundation and selected as a
test subject for scp-666 due to his
history of drug abuse the foundation
expected to be adding his body to the
incineration pile sometime soon none of
the researchers working on the case
predicted what actually ended up
happening Paul was forced to enter the
yurt not long after he found himself
standing in a place he'd done everything
to try to forget the dark graffiti
stained alley Where he'd been sold his
first hit this was the place the place
that destroyed his life every bad
decision he'd ever made could be traced
back to here and specifically to one man
Frank Frank was his first dealer and now
here he was standing right across from
him once more Frank was grinning like a
demon come on Polly he said he got it
trash we both know what you're gonna do
don't you feel it the itch come on one
more hit Polly that's all you need to
feel better it's time to take your
medicine Frank or this thing pretending
to be frank was right he did feel the
itch he did want it maybe he was no
better than this he began to reach out
towards Frank but then he abruptly
pulled his hand back Frank's eyes
widened and genuine surprise as Paul
replied I'm sorry that's not me anymore
scp-66-1 gave a smile and said maybe it
isn't Polly maybe it isn't when Paul
Abels was removed from the scp-66 yard
by one of the attending guards the
foundation researchers discovered
something amazing Paul was very much
alive and more incredibly he didn't feel
the Cravings anymore his addiction was
gone and further tests showed that Paul
wasn't a one-off event in fact anyone
who denies the temptation of scp-66 will
see their addictions miraculously
disappear when they finally leave after
this it became clear to the foundation
that scp-66 isn't just a way to punish
addicts it's a kind of test those who
want to change were willing to truly
confront their demons and resist the
pull of Temptation are rewarded with the
one thing they want most in their life
freedom from their addiction
scp-66 can be your doom or your
salvation and like most things in life
you get what you give one fine morning
your distant Aunt Carol came to your
family home in an almost frantic state
of excitement Carol had always been a
bit eccentric totally harmless of course
but what you describe as being on the
more zealous side of religious
predictably she wanted to ask you and
your family to come to church with her
seeing as you don't see on Carol often
you and your family decide that there's
no harm in indulging her you're not an
atheist family by any means in fact you
were all race Catholic but it felt like
it'd been forever since you last went to
church Aunt Carol wanted to show you and
your family the special celebrations
that went on at her church you remember
her practically grabbing you by the
wrist and dragging you to the building
her eyes filled with a crazed enthusiasm
that's when you saw something in
incredibly strange there were Shadows
moving behind the elaborate stained
glass windows thousands of tiny Shadows
starting around and this low humming
noise you faintly recognize what was
that noise it was the Cry of cicadas but
this was only early spring what were
cicadas doing awake at this time of year
you didn't get much time to ponder this
question in the next few seconds you and
the entire church were surrounded by
heavy duty tactical Vehicles what
appeared to be a large and heavily armed
SWAT team poured out of the vehicles
unbeknownst to you these were a mobile
task force sent in by the SCP Foundation
specifically
mtfy99 also known as The Altar Boys a
specially trained group of foundation
agents used for anomalies of a religious
nature you your aunt and the rest of
your family are rounded up to be
debriefed and given amnestics one of the
last memories they took from you was the
side of foundation agents dragging
bloody bodies out of the church as the
doors open thousands of cicadas streamed
out and disappeared into the skies but
these weren't like any kind of cicada
you'd ever seen they were beautiful the
rainbow colored Wings reminded you of
ornate's stained glass who could have
guessed that these pretty little bugs
are tied to an entity very likely to
bring about an XK Class end of the world
scenario someday in the future the bugs
the bodies in the church and even your
aunt's incredibly strange Behavior All
Fall underneath the umbrella of a
ketterclass anomaly known as
scp-3004 but to truly understand this
anomaly that was once thought to be
destroyed and the implications of it
still living today we need to go back
600 years to Ireland in the 15th century
this era was believed to be the origin
of a Gaelic religious movement known as
katelanji or the singers in English a
splinter sect of druidism but this was
no fringe cult the singers were a
mainstream religion in the British Isles
for several hundred years its members
included people of all social classes
from lowly peasants to powerful and
respected figures they mingled heavily
with Christians mostly Irish Catholics
and at some point in history came close
to overtaking Christianity as the
dominant religion in Ireland so who were
these people if they're supposedly such
a large part of recent history in the
area like most Druids their relationship
with nature was a key part of their
belief system in particular they prized
an extinct species of cicada known as
sycadera luculenta or the stained glass
cicada in English the life cycle of
birth and resurrection that the cicadas
underwent fascinated the singers and
they performed a number of holy rituals
around it one recorded ritual was the
celebration of children entering
adulthood that was marked by them first
losing their baby teeth but the rituals
of the singers accidentally opened some
kind of door to a being from a different
plane of reality dubbed
scp-3004-1 by the foundation this being
is an immensely powerful font form that
the foundation believes to be a pitis
phage or faith eater it appears to have
been attracted to our universe by the
rituals of the singers and so took a
form relevant to their beliefs namely a
huge cicada in order to feed on their
faith if things had stopped there then
this would be an almost innocent
symbiotic relationship but the
interactions between
scp-3004-1 and our world led to
dangerous consequences due to its
powerful reality warping abilities for
example during some rituals huge numbers
of stained glass cicadas would burst
from the mouths of those participating
often causing them to choke to death
other times 3004-1 would manifest
physically in the sky above its new
worshipers causing painful boils on
whoever witnessed it and occasionally
symptoms akin to radiation sickness it
appeared that 3004-1 one was growing
more powerful over time and its rise to
power was intrinsically linked to the
rituals of the singers and the existence
of the stained glass cicadas two groups
that predated the foundation the
vatican's congregation for otherworldly
acts and the English government's Royal
Society for the imprisonment of
abnormality essentially performed an
all-out religious genocide on the
singers no meaningful trace of the
religion was left when they were done
aside from their own records while they
were at it they also exterminated all
the stained glass cicadas leading to a
complete stop of all scp-3004 activity
it seemed like despite the great human
and ecological cost the anomaly had been
neutralized a few centuries later though
a series of strange cicada-related
anomalous events started to occur across
the United States a strange man
seemingly made almost entirely from
cicada kinten would appear at
christenings weddings and funerals each
time his presence caused the people in
attendance to do and experience horrific
things and lead to legacies of hardship
and death that would linger for decades
this became known as
scp-2852 or cousin Johnny and it should
have been the first clue that the
nightmare of
scp-3004 was resurfacing but since 3004
was already archived as neutralized
nobody made the connection sometime
later
scp-2852 incident ceased and around that
exact time
scp-3004 instances started Anew it
manifested in the form of strange
anomalous activities taking place at
Christian church services specifically
those from Roman Catholic Eastern
Catholic Anglican and Episcopalian
communities the only Clues to Outsiders
would be an increase in reported Church
attendance and an increase in deaths
from natural causes within the community
these two stats were how the foundation
first noticed something was amiss just
as it had done with the singers
centuries before
scp-3004-1 had latched onto the beliefs
and rituals of Christians and was using
this new connection to harvest more
faith for sustenance the results were
twofold first religious favor and
excitement to attend church services saw
a huge increase secondly the actual
content of these Services took a hard
turn for the horrific much like cousin
Johnny infiltrations this really isn't
for the faint of heart by any definition
for example young people with
christ-like Stigmata wounds being bitten
to death by priests children removing
the teeth of priests before they all
start vomiting huge numbers of stained
glass cicadas that were extremely
unpleasant rituals involving castration
and even a pregnant woman giving birth
to even more swarms of stained glass
cicadas we could go on but you probably
get the idea rituals inspired by
scp-3004-1 are horrific and all seem to
involve the same extinct breed of
stained glass cicadas worshiped by the
singers before their Annihilation but
how can these insects which have been
dubbed
scp-3004-2 be here in the present if the
foundation forerunners made them extinct
so many centuries ago the answer is
simple but strange while they have all
the Hallmarks of being alive the stained
glass cicada is present during modern
iterations of scp-3004 events aren't
actually real genetic tests have shown
that they're actually made from a mix of
wood and real stained glass these
insects Fly Away From The Scene after
the rituals are completed traveling
around 600 miles from the site before
disappearing completely the foundation
was growing concerned about the nature
of scp-3004 especially given that
instances were becoming more frequent
and harder to contain Foundation
scientists determined that the creature
known as 3004-1 likely existed within a
layer of reality just above our own and
if it ever managed to reach our reality
the World level of violence and Chaos it
could cause would likely lead to an XK
Class end of the world scenario drastic
actions would once again be needed to
prevent this so they devised an
emergency containment procedure that
would only be used as a last resort the
procedure known as protocol damantio
audbestias would use a mixture of mass
amnesic treatment and thermal objects to
completely erase Christianity from not
only the modern world but all of history
in hopes of cutting off
scp-3004-1's food supply to kill the
entity or at least prevent it from
entering our world the plan would Center
on placing a powerful Roman Catholic
reality warper who volunteered for the
job of course into an anomalous group of
machines known as the Lions by
submitting the reality warper to a
lifetime of suffering and essentially
erasing him from existence so too will
it erase the world's full knowledge of
Christianity and hopefully save the
world this man will be become the last
martyr dying for all of humanity he will
become the last Saint Saint Jude the
Damned bulwark against Darkness you
might ask are you sure that's necessary
there's so much we don't know about
3004-1 do we know for a fact that it's
dangerous enter agent Timothy Letterman
a member of mobile task force Sigma 25
also known as Ghostbusters Letterman was
part of a foundation project known as
sightsee Lux using an astral projection
technology that would free his
Consciousness from his body and allow it
to travel freely between metaphysical
planes in plain English they could use
Letterman's floating mind as a kind of
spy and insert it into
3004-1's Dimension they achieved this by
capturing one of 3004-1's false stained
glass cicadas and releasing it again
allowing Letterman's mind to follow at
home to its Master however what we
thought would be a simple Intel
gathering mission turned into a complete
nightmare Letterman found that 3000
4-1's Dimension was entirely void aside
from the entity itself and the millions
of buzzing stained glass cicadas The
Entity was so huge and so complex that
it physically hurt to look at Letterman
observed that its form kept shifting
from a giant cicada to an old man to a
cicada nailed to a wooden cross to an
infinite mess of wood and stained glass
but even more terrifying than its
physical appearance were the contents of
its mind 3004-1 forced itself into agent
Letterman's brain and in that moment he
finally understood it the entity which
had no concept of metaphors allegory or
the Divide between fact and fiction
truly believed that it was the abrahamic
god depicted in the Bible and that all
Christians are lovingly worshiping it in
its rituals it was imposing some of the
bloodiest parts of the Bible onto its
flock believing that's what they wanted
all the while it fed on their faith
growing bigger and more powerful
Letterman found that just being there
with the creature was hurting his soul
if it wasn't a god yet he believed it
had the power to become one in time and
he advised the foundation shouldn't send
anyone else to its Dimension it was too
great a risk to all life on Earth
perhaps to prevent the horrible fate of
all of us being destroyed by 3004-1 a
racing Christianity would be a worthy
sacrifice that is if it actually works
after all they thought destroying the
singers would neutralize 3004 once and
for all and yet here it is again for all
we know we may just be prolonging the
inevitable if you've ever studied
ancient Egypt in your history class then
you're probably familiar with the way
they buried their pharaohs when a king
of Egypt died their body would be
entombed in a huge sarcophagus usually
after being mummified mummification was
the process that the ancient Egyptians
used to preserve their dead safeguarding
a corpse with special chemicals and the
application of cloth almost like
bandages this was done to keep cadavers
from decaying usually because of the
belief that this would carry over into
the Afterlife and it wasn't just the
Egyptians that practice mummification
either mummies of human beings or
animals have been found on almost every
continent in the world sometimes a body
can even be accidentally mummified
through exposure to extreme cold lack of
oxygen or other environmental factors
that help keep the deceased preserved
fun fact the oldest recorded mummy isn't
even one left behind by the ancient
Egyptians it is actually a naturally
mummified severed head estimated to be 6
000 years old it was Unearthed in South
America in 1936. yes corpse preservation
techniques can indeed be strange but
none are Stranger Than
scp-1176 also known by the nickname the
mellified man now as you may have
already pieced together the mellified
man is a mummified corpse but not quite
like the ones you would expect to find
buried in the pyramids estimated by
Foundation researchers to have been a
man in his mid-30s when he died
scp-1176 is a corpse that has degraded
so much over the centuries that it has
made DNA examination impossible
According to some of the SCP
foundation's best Minds
scp-1176 is possibly of Arabian ancestry
and thought to have passed away sometime
during either the 10th or the 11th
Century's A.D the this is certainly not
your ordinary mummy and it definitely
isn't like the kind you'd see in a
Cheesy black and white horror movie or
on an old episode of Scooby-Doo
scp-1176 is absolutely undoubtedly dead
by all clinical definitions it doesn't
show any signs of breathing and the
processes of blood circulation or
metabolism have long since stopped
however despite the Decay suffered by
the rest of the body
scp-1176's brain seems to have remained
intact for almost 10 whole centuries not
just intact but active the foundation's
researchers have confirmed that the
brain has a constant level of electrical
activity consistent with people
experiencing stage 3 non-rapid eye
movement sleep known colloquially as
deep sleep so a mummy with an active
albeit Dorman brain how does an ancient
culture manage to achieve preservation
like this alien technology cryogenic
sleep Chambers suspended animation no
not quite
scp-1176 exists in its current state in
part because the body has been nullified
now this was a process a lot like
mummification but instead of wrapping
them in cloth a melified man or a human
mummy confection was created by
submerging a dead body in Honey
according to historical records elderly
men in Arabic countries would sometimes
willingly volunteer themselves for this
process why because the goal was to turn
their bodies into a healing confection
in other words an elaborate sweet
delicacy created from a preserved corpse
that's right ancient cultures had candy
made from dead people all the
information the foundation has gathered
about scp-1176 seems to point to the
body being one such mellified man when
extracting the remaining bodily fluids
from the corpse instead of fighting
blood or other normal substances
Foundation researchers discovered that
scp-1176 was full of a viscous gold
colored liquid that they designated as
scp-1176-1 further testing of this fluid
revealed it to be you guessed it honey
specifically it was a type known as
clover honey made by a species called
the Anatolian honeybee this stuff was
everywhere filling
scp-1176 entirely so much so that honey
was even coming out of the body's pores
this is due to the nature of the
mullification process typically before
death a person who had offered to
sacrifice their own body would stop
eating any food instead their diet would
consist solely of honey and nothing else
they would even bathe in it submerging
their entire body in the substance
inside and out until their sweat and
even their feces were pure honey this
honey only diet would eventually kill
the donor and their corpse would be
placed in a stone coffin which was also
filled up with even more honey after
approximately 100 years what would be
left was human mummy confection a
honey-based candy of sorts that could be
then sold at Street Markets for a high
value price why was it so expensive well
not just because it was literally made
from a dead person but also because this
confection was believed to possess rare
and Powerful healing properties
everything from the common cold to
Broken Bones was said to be cured by it
despite it leaking out of scp-1176 the
honey doesn't seem to ever run out even
when tested under varying conditions it
seems like the mellified man actively
produces more of the sweet golden
substance acting as the source rather
than a container with a finite amount
and yes it is still edible after several
centuries in fact it contains an
abundance of essential vitamins and
nutrients according to the foundation's
testing the honey produced by scp-1176
can suppress the feeling of hunger for
up to 18 whole hours and there are no
long-term side effects for most that eat
it however the is not the case for
everyone the foundation has learned that
any person without the blood type A B
positive will have a severe allergic
reaction should they consume any of
scp-1176-1 the symptoms include acute
humulosis which means the red blood
cells won't break down properly and
renial failure which is when the kidneys
stop functioning this all results in
depth for most of the subjects without a
B positive blood who were fed
scp-1176-1 the symptoms for these
unlucky people were the same as
receiving an incompatible blood type
after a transfusion in 1985 the SCP
Foundation launched a raid on a facility
in Asmara erotria which at the time was
owned by a group called the Mana
charitable Foundation agents had been
dispatched to this facility after
various rumors and reports that pointed
to this location being the source of a
strange honey substance this anomalous
liquid was being shipped to a number of
areas in Ethiopia that had been stricken
with famine pretty easy to guess where
the Mana charitable Foundation got all
that honey right the problem was because
scp-1176-1 caused adverse effects on
people without a B positive blood a
considerable amount of civilians had
died from consuming it hence the SCP
Foundation was forced to step in when
scp-1176 was first uncovered the body
had been stored inside a large Stone
sarcophagus as was part of the ancient
practice of creating a melified man
there was also a copper pipe and spigot
installed by the Mana charitable
Foundation to extract the honey from
within the lids sides and inside of the
sarcophagus itself had a number of
Egyptian hieroglyphics inscribed Within
These were mostly spells and ceremonial
texts written as a way to protect the
individual that was to become the
mellified man there were also
inscriptions written in the dialect that
was an early precursor to the Arabic
language however these sections had been
replaced with updated versions In
classical Arab one of these read
Abdallah ibin Salah ibin Ayub IBN Nasir
fifteenth son of the great Sheik
illegible was put to the fast of Honey
on the first of rajab in the year of the
Hijra III illegible and died on the 15th
of Ramadan the great Imam al-yasuf has
sealed him within the ancient vessel
marked with the signs decreed by the
Ancients to ferment in Honey for 100
years and bring Aid to the people in
time of need much like a headstone used
to Mark the grave of someone who has
passed the sarcophagus that scp-1176 was
in featured a passage commemorating a
man who gave his life and body to heal
others sounds nice right but there was
another inscription written Elsewhere on
the stone sarcophagus which translated a
dire warning beware Imam for the mark of
Iblis is upon this one according to the
rest of the second inscription the tomb
containing scp-1176 had been opened
before during a time of great famine
Imam al-malik had ordered it to be open
so that
scp-1176-1 honey could be used to feed
the starving people jars upon jars were
filled with the anomalous golden liquid
and brought to the Sheik the ruler of
the land as well as sent to the people
suffering from the lack of food however
the very next day a number of these
people fell ill stricken by a terrible
fever that ultimately claimed their
lives only the Sheik his brothers and
his sons who had all eaten the honey
survived any others who hadn't been
killed by the fever accused the Sheik
and his family of sorcery and these
surviving subjects attempted to destroy
the body that had produced this cursed
nectar but when the Sheik's people found
the melified man they witnessed in
horror as the body stood upright dancing
around as it screamed and taunted the
people al-malik declared that the Devil
Himself sent an evil spirit to corrupt
scp-1176 the honey confection was meant
to be a means of healing but it had been
and corrupted the sarcophagus was then
sealed and the inscription on it
finished with the following caution to
any that found it may God strike down
any who would break these seals
countless centuries later once the SCP
Foundation had recovered
scp-1176 and the sarcophagus containing
it they began testing with the melified
man their goal was to determine how much
of the
scp-1176-1 honey the ancient corpse
could produce perhaps in the hopes of
using this substance as a form of
hunger-relieving field ration for their
operatives removing the body from its
sarcophagus Foundation researchers
placed scp-1176 on a metal grate
designed to drain the honey as it was
produced instead of allowing it to build
up over the course of several hours more
and more honey seemed to be produced
beginning at a rate of almost a liter
per hour to almost 56 liters every hour
but then after 10 and a half hours of
producing what seemed like an endless
flow of Honey something onyx expected
happened the deceased body of the
mellified man dead for hundreds if not
thousands of years woke up Foundation
staff detected a spike in brain activity
if you cast your mind back to earlier
you'll remember that
scp-1176's brain had managed to survive
and stay intact long after it should
have decayed the mellified man opened
his eyes and immediately started to
wildly flail around he made a number of
distressed sounds the long dead body
trying to crawl towards the outskirts of
the testing chamber thanks to so many of
its organs and muscles having withered
away over the years
scp-1176 was barely able to see or
understand its surroundings it couldn't
speak not properly anyway given that its
tongue had long since decayed the
foundation's Personnel moved in to try
and restrain the ancient and now
animated body hoping to sedate it before
scp-1176 caused any lasting damage to
itself eventually staff were able to
force SCP 1176 back into its sarcophagus
slamming the stone lid back in place and
trapping it within they could hear the
once human creatures screeching and
vocalizing from inside bashing against
the inside of the stone coffin with its
head and limbs it took three whole hours
of this for the melified man to return
to its usual state by which time its
ancient bones were fractured Beyond
repair
scp-1176 is a sad tale of a man who had
willingly given his life to be a source
of healing for people in need he allowed
himself to be mellified turning into a
confection that could bring an end to
famine and yet somehow this was
corrupted and turned into something that
spread fever and pestilence for now the
mellified man sleeps but his brain is
still alive inside while he might be
asleep he may never be able to rest in
1961 the SCP Foundation discovered a
town that was completely
weight of all life not long before their
arrival Darrington North Carolina had
been a community with high aspirations a
deeply religious Township of devout
Christians many of whom were seeking
greater Prosperity from their lives but
now their home was a ghost town with no
sign of any prior Darrington resident to
be found where in the hell had they all
gone it oddly seemed like the population
of an entire town would all
simultaneously decide to up sticks and
leave two pastors new but then again
maybe the citizens of Darrington hadn't
left at all perhaps they weren't even
really still human and had taken up
residence somewhere much darker like
underground this is the story of one of
the earliest known instances of a
phenomenon now known under the
designation of
scp-3089 or to use its alternative name
that old-time religion when the SCP
Foundation arrived in a desolate
Darrington to find the town folk had all
vanished they immediately began an
investigation into the exact house and
whys the answers to what exactly had
happened here after all while not a huge
Place Darrington was home to nearly a
thousand residents and that many people
don't just disappear if they even had
disappeared and weren't just dormant but
what the foundation uncovered was a
gruesome discovery that led them to not
only demolishing the entire North
Carolinian town but purchasing all the
land around it to keep the area under
permanent observation prior to the
demolition however the ministry of
Sevenfold blessing had been one of the
oldest buildings in Darrington much like
most Town churches and it was while
searching the offices of this church
that the foundation cleanup Crews
discovered their first piece of evidence
the initial clue about what had happened
to this deserted town they recovered a
series of cassette tapes each with a
recording of sermons that had been given
within the ministry of Sevenfold
blessing these were all delivered by One
Pastor Bartholomew Jenner the first
having been recorded on August 17th of
1959 two years earlier my friends I want
to talk to you about what the Bible
offers tonight Pastor Jenner began in
the first of these recordings I want to
talk to you about what you are owed I
want to talk to you about I want to talk
to those of you who are struggling right
now to those of you who have hardship
and pain maybe you've heard that the
Bible only nourishes the spirit that God
only provides for our Immortal Souls
well my friends I'm here to tell you
that this is simply not true Pastor
Bartholomew Jenner seemed to be focused
on the discussion of very real relatable
problems after all what person hasn't
felt unsatisfied with their life at one
point or another and this was apparently
no different for the people of
Darrington many of you can think of
places in your lives where you have not
yet risen where you are not yet
Victorious marriage finances hell but do
not fret my friends God wants you to
rise he has cleared a path for you it is
one littered with his Earthly Treasures
to claim them you only need to shed your
old selves and be reborn the bastard was
merely using the shared faith of the
township to help reaffirm that their
struggles were not the be-all and all of
their lives or at least that's how it
first appeared but the religious
practices taking place in this first
recording would soon take a bizarre turn
making it clear there was something far
more Sinister even cult-like going on in
the ministry of seventh-fold blessing
now if you would some of the ladies from
the mayor's office were kind enough to
collect these cicada shells pass along
each of you take one yes the children
too be careful very careful they are
fragile each of you take one and hold it
in your left hand yes the left hand not
the right your left the shells of dead
cicadas hardly seem like common fare for
a sermon like this although as the
recording continued it was easy to
understand that Pastor Jenner intended
these discarded insect carapaces to be
something of a metaphor even if they
were pretty gross especially to some of
the younger members of his congregation
he explained to the Darrington residents
that these cicada shells Were Meant To
Be symbolic of whatever hardship the
citizens were currently struggling with
in their lives whether it was work a
marriage or an ill family member then
came the next part of this unorthodox
practice the pastor instructed everyone
in the congregation to picture
themselves holding their biggest problem
in their left hand now I want you to
squeeze your left hand squeeze it into a
fist feel that problem cracking like old
dried out paper fill it crumbled to dust
Jenner told them the residents of
Darrington did so crushing the cicada
shells until there was nothing left
everyone open your eyes don't you feel
better strong this is what is offered
our hardships are like the shell we
shall cast them aside even as they
crumble God has cleared a path needless
to say the foundation agents that
recovered the tapes of Pastor Jenner's
odd sermons weren't exactly sure what to
make of them and as unusual as they were
the recordings did little to indicate
where the townspeople of Darrington
North Carolina had disappeared to but as
they listened further what they found
was even more unsettling that an entire
Congregation of people crushing cicada
shells in the second recording dated
December 19th of 1959 Pastor Jenner was
once again presiding over his
congregation he had just finished
quoting a passage from Matthew chapter
25 verse 30 which related to a Biblical
tale known as the parable of the talents
in this story a master puts his servants
in charge of a differently sized portion
of his wealth while he is away then
judges them based on whether or not his
servants make a profit using his money
the third servant who had received the
least talents meaning an amount of money
was punished for burying his share in
the ground cast out into the outer
Darkness to face weeping and gnashing of
teeth it was after making mention of
this unprofitable servant that Pastor
Jenner went on to address even more of
the bizarre almost ritualistic practices
he had been introducing to his sermons
now some of you have expressed concerns
over the new sacraments a view of even
call call them sacrilege and yet have we
not prospered have these same naysayers
these same doubting Thomases not
profited from all good works the pastor
declared I have shown you how to heal
the sick with the Lord's Prayer and the
blood of an unbaptized child I've shown
you how to see your future in the
stemming entrails of a quiver and Crow
I've shown you the path to Glory but I
cannot make you follow this path I can
only show it to you it is you and you
alone who must follow it who must rise
and share your old self shed your old
self the words immediately call to mind
the image of the cicadas insects that
discard their outer carapaces and emerge
Anew bugs that also burrow into the
ground and wait lying dormant under the
Earth for years at a time all before
they emerge rising up again so they can
spread it was becoming clear that Pastor
Jenner was certainly deviating further
and further from the church's normal
religious practices his bold and blatant
descriptions of what sounded like
ritualistic sacrifices were shocking
enough to hear speaking of using blood
and entrails to bring the town the
prosperity it sought but if that wasn't
bad enough the worst was still yet to
come contained within the third and
final recording unlike the previous
cassettes most of the sermon from June 7
1960 was almost completely
unintelligible and without any Visual
Evidence to go along with it it was hard
for the foundation to make out exactly
what was going on it began with another
quote from Matthew This Time chapter 28
verse 6 which made mention of the
resurrection of Jesus that he had risen
and that people should come and see
where the Lord lay not a metaphor my
friends Pastor Jenner explained before
urging his congregation to join in some
kind of formation stat followed mothers
behind their daughters fathers behind
their sons turned to face the uh the
recording became unintelligible again
after that point was with only a few
more words being audible the pastors
seem to have gathered the townsfolk of
Darrington presumably for some new form
of ritual he encouraged the town's
children to close their eyes and pray
before reminding the congregation that
God sacrificed the life of his only son
Jesus frighteningly it appeared that
Pastor Jenner was implying the adults of
Darrington should do the same one of the
next fragments of his sermon that could
be deciphered declared lamb is
slaughtered to feed the lion the sun is
slaughtered to fade between more and
more noise interfering with the
recording Pastor Jenner could be heard
saying The Pact is complete this WOW
shall be our Paradise before he
encouraged his congregation or those who
were left to dig deep and wait then came
perhaps the most horrifying part to the
tape the remainder of the recording
lasted 30 minutes comprised of pure
static or the foundation agents
listening to it assumed at first that it
was just interference but further audio
analysis seemed to just that the long
continuous mass of hissing wasn't static
at all it was The chittering Sound of
Insects like the noise made by cicadas
for a Time the incident at Darrington
left the foundation baffled there seemed
to be no clear answer as to what had
happened not one of the town's residents
were anywhere to be found and on top of
that there were no bodies no remains of
any kind to speak of if they were dead
there would at least be some kind of
trace and then there were all the
questions raised by Pastor Bartholomew
Jenner's strange sermons why do these
seem so focused on enacting rituals did
any of his methods really benefit the
town and why did he place so much
emphasis on cicadas of all things
answers were few and far between
although almost six decades after the
foundation discovered the desolate town
of Darrington a new development would
come to light to be more accurate it was
56 years later on the 11th of January
2017 a foundation agent named Daniel
Mitchell was patrolling the area that
had formerly been Darrington North
Carolina before the foundation had
demolished all traces of the Town by
this point the SCP Foundation had long
thought that they had figured out
exactly what scp-3089 was they had even
encountered it emerging in a number of
different forms in both 2007 and 2015.
however it was what Daniel Mitchell
happened across during the routine
monthly Patrol that revealed the
horrifying Truth at the outskirts of the
area where the town had once been a
series of sinkhals had opened up at some
point between the previous monthly check
and this one in early 2017 and if you
think that these sinkholes caused a
disturbance in the earth and uncovered
all the bodies of the former residents
of Darrington you'd be wrong it was Far
Far stranger the foundation conducted a
full-scale examination of the sinkholes
around the demolished North Carolinian
town and these weren't just a few
patches of loose ground that had sunk
through the Geological Survey the
foundation carried out quickly revealed
that these sinkholes led to an extensive
network of tunnels underground they
extended several hundred kilometers
outwards practically covering the entire
underside of where Darrington had been
the tunnels seemed far too big than any
other created by any natural means but
the entire network also appeared too
rudimentary too imperfect to have been
carved using any modern excavation
technology like a large drill plus if
any equipment like that had been on site
the foundation would have noticed as
they kept the area monitored it was
almost like something had been burrowing
through the ground only to eventually
crawl back up to the surface resulting
in the sinkholes what's more of the
foundation's geological tests suggested
that the network of tunnels was almost
four decades old that would have placed
the date of their creation about 10
years after The Disappearance of
everyone in Darrington naturally the
foundation immediately launched a
mission to explore more of the tunnels
before even completing a full sweep of
the underground space in its entirety
they had made another Discovery
contained within the tunnels was over a
whole ton of organic material that had
been mostly preserved without
decomposing too much the SCP Foundation
began Gathering samples for testing
fighting most of this material to be
severely desiccated dermis tissue that
is the dense layer of skin beneath the
epidermis and it had all been entirely
dried out but that wasn't all the
testing uncovered according to genetic
analysis the tissue had two distinct
types of DNA present the first being
easily identified as human genetic
material which made sense despite the
material lacking in moisture the dermis
tissue didn't match the skin of any
other mammal but then there was the
other DNA present combined with the
expected human DNA was the presence of
something else that the foundation
researchers had quite some difficulty
finding a match for eventually they
determined that this genetic material
entangled with the human DNA belong to
the sycadata Montana better known as The
New Forest cicada cicadas again cicada
DNA mixed with human DNA discovered in a
large network of underground tunnels all
beneath the same town where a pastor had
his congregation crushed cicada shells
in their left hands during one of his
sermons ten years before the sinkhole
incident the foundation was alerted to a
particular YouTube channel by the name
of Kai Sanchez positively rich on the
surface Kai was one of the many online
grifters preaching about how easy it was
to quickly achieve an obscene amount of
wealth by simply believing in yourself
usually if not always these types of
people were trying to scan Their
audience of loyal subscribers into
investing in some kind of illicit
money-making scheme or any number of
other cons promising their followers
easy money that never came bakai
Sanchez's channel was slightly different
so much so the founding station had to
contain his entire audience deeming them
to have been affected by
scp-3089 the video that caught the
foundation's attention was an hour-long
upload from Kai entitled seven secrets
to ascend the ladder of prosperity there
was that word again Prosperity the same
thing Pastor Jenner had promised his
entire congregation in Darrington and
the similarities didn't end there in his
video much like the pastor during his
sermons Kai Sanchez encouraged his
audience to visualize their success in
order to achieve it he implied that the
human consciousness could impact reality
for example if his viewers just imagined
themselves having a bigger bank account
or looking more attractive then these
things would manifest themselves into
the real world one of Kai's secrets to
ascend the ladder of prosperity was as
follows the visualize your ascendance
reimagine yourself as someone who can
reach the top of that ladder shed your
old identity tear it off throw it aside
like dead skin you won't need it not
where you're going the resemblance to
Pastor Jenner's sermons was uncanny
Kai's video even encouraged that his
audience leaves scraps out to lure
strike cats into their homes and then
once they had one to take a knife and
well you remember what happened in
Darrington but Kai Sanchez made sure to
specify remember to hold the knife with
your left hand another online community
was tagged by the foundation for similar
teachings this group of insular men were
trying to apply the same methodology
primarily to attract women however they
also reasoned it could be used to
improve their own financial status and
physical stature all done through
visualizing and believing that doing so
would make these things improve that
having faith would grant them Prosperity
this Disturbed Community even tried to
use bug Rattlers to emit frequencies to
Aid and try attracting women contained
within these Rattlers were the preserved
remains of cicadas male cicadas have Tim
balls structures on their outer shell
that emit a loud hissing chittering
noise that they often use to find a mate
after spending so much time dormant
underground before burrowing up to the
surface and if you've been paying
attention you might be able to guess
exactly where this is going
scp-3089 is a phenomenon that occurs
within communities of people who are
seeking some form of prosperity whether
that community be a town a group of
like-minded people online or any other
group of collected individuals the
particular type of prosperity these
people are all seeking can be anything
from spiritual enlightenment to
financial success the SCP Foundation
does not yet quite understand exactly
how scp-3089 starts only that the
community is affected by it will attempt
to achieve their chosen material Success
Through the application of rituals like
visualizing what they hope to overcome
and Achieve and practicing sacrifices in
short these people have to believe these
acts will grant them what they want they
need to be willing to go far enough to
do unspeakable things they need to have
faith although what they don't realize
is some things can feed on that Faith
they can Harvest it before these
communities realize the terrible things
that they have done or who exactly has
tricked them into performing these
rituals they'll begin to undergo a
horrific transformation process known as
scp-3089-b it begins in the Chrysalis
Stage members of a community that have
been affected by scp-3089 Will
experienced a decline state of
metabolism now classified as an instance
of
scp-3089-a their brain activity heart
rate and body temperature will all begin
to lower over a period of between three
and six hours these people will then
suffer a change to their epidermis the
outer layer of skin it starts to harden
until it does form a dense brittle
substance like a shell next comes the
second stage of
scp-3089-b metamorphosis internally
scp-3089-a individuals will develop a
number of tetramas a type of germ cell
tumor that can contain several different
types of tissue such as hair muscle and
bone during the next two or three weeks
these tumors will expand and dissolve
the person's soft tissue then there's
the final stage emergence an instance of
scp-3089-a will exit its Dorman state
that began in the initial stage once
they have awoken then something exits
the outer epidermal shell it will not
communicate some will retain remnants of
internal organs such as eyes or lungs
however these are vestigial no longer
serving any purpose the brain functions
deviate from any normal human patterns
having completed the process the this
thing we'll attempt to burrow down into
the soil via any means at its disposal
an outer shell digging into the soil the
tunnels underneath Darrington the
genetic material uncovered below dermis
tissue with two types of DNA a mix of
human and cicada there is something out
there it is preying on people's Faith
their longing for Prosperity than when
these communities are presented with
someone who can take advantage of that
Faith Like Pastor Jenner or Kai Sanchez
they find themselves encouraged to push
their faith to its furthest limit and
then they are rewarded by becoming
something else something nightmarish the
question is when they wake up and crawl
back out from their tunnels leaving a
sinkhole in their wake where do these
cicada creatures go the anomalous
religions at the SCP Foundation has
cataloged and studied over the years are
many in number and bottomless in depth
with specialized parathiological
researchers limiting themselves to just
one or maybe two faiths diving fully
into a religion of their choice and
mastering its forbidden knowledge but
the foundation is careful to make sure
that those researching these faiths
don't succumb to their beliefs as many
anomalous religions are dangerous to the
organizations in practice involving
tasks such as making blood packs with
ancient gods or modifying one's body to
better suit a Divine Purpose there's
some seriously nasty stuff involved in
the immaterial world almost to the point
where it makes you wonder why anyone
would be suckered into joining up with
what appears to be from the outside just
another Cult of crazies but let's not
generalize religions even those that are
non-anomalous are all strange from the
outside even if one may seem natural to
you but one anomalous religion stands
out from all the rest as having more
active followers more history and more
doc documented culture than any other
and that is sarcasism hold on to your
flesh because today on SCP explained
we're going to be answering the question
what is sarcasism and Hope fully don't
get distracted and ritually sacrifice
you the viewer in the name of the grand
karcissist ion along the way let's get
to it meat bags before we begin it's
important to note that sarcasism is an
incredibly dense and deep religion and
that covering every last detail of it in
a short period of time would be a
Herculean Nye impossible task for even
the most well-read sarkic lore Masters
so where would you even start what is
sarcasism to best understand that we're
going to bring you back all the way to
the beginning of human history to the
ancient world of the Eurasian continent
where sprawling empires ruled and war
between them was an all too common
occurrence in what is now Central
Siberia the David Empire ruled with an
iron fist the Deva were a warrior
culture with militarism Conquest
gruesome human sacrifice and thematurgic
Magic rituals being universally
consistent in their culture according to
the few historical accounts available
that make mention of the empire the
davites practiced anomalous magic Arcane
rituals and sacrifices that bolstered
their power longevity and standing
within their society the empire was
ruled by a Theocratic aristocracy called
the Deva those who were especially
attuned to the anomalous world who
practice cannibalism and thalmaturgy and
whose bodies were so warped and Modified
by Decades of magic alteration that
Foundation historians would come to the
conclusion that the Deva were so
Divergent from modern humans that they
could be considered a separate species
altogether but how the Deva relate to
sarcasism Remains the question and the
answer is found in the Empire's slave
owning culture the devites owned many
many slaves people they had brought or
taken from their lands as a sign of pure
devite power in the form of ownership
over another human being David
city-states had massive sprawling slave
populations and among those was a young
boy by the name of ion ions appear would
be depicted over the years by sarkic art
and culture as inconclusive and varied
whether it was their gender or even the
question of whether or not ion resembled
a human The Cult of Personality that
would crop up around ion would be a
testament to sarcasism's eventual
widespread culture but it was here in
ancient Western Siberia where those
seeds of sarkicism originated according
to the most prominent sarkic texts ion
was a slave like many others in the
David Empire Born Into Slavery by a
devite mother and a concubine father the
circumstances of ion's birth indicate
that he was destined to be a slave from
the onset but there was something
remarkable about them ion in the eyes of
his Masters was different from other
slaves he was intelligent and so much so
that the decision was made for ION to
serve under a devite priestess where he
could hone his skills to serve the
empire in ways unlike the other slaves
who toiled away constructing massive
public works or died in foreign lands on
the field of battle ion did not
understand what differentiated him from
others and why he deserved such special
treatment but it was the realization
that the only thing separating him from
his Masters was the possession of power
that would serve as the basis for
sarcasism's founding doctrines ion
watched in horror as those they knew
succumbed to the back-breaking work that
the Empire forced upon its slaves and
how prevalent death and destruction were
among its people inside ion grew a great
rage for the Daylights who flaunted
their power over others in the form of
slavery he wished to transcend the
physical limitations that kept him and
his fellow slaves in bondage and service
to the devites ion knew that their
masters practiced thamaturgy a form of
magic that granted great power to its
users and in a brutal world where power
is what defines who is master and who is
slave the prospects of achieving it
became more important to ion than
anything else if he could harness such
power for himself ion should break free
from the chains of slavery that kept him
subservient to those devite Masters he
would achieve apotheosis the belief that
an individual could Ascend to godhood
through raw power and unbridled will
over time ion's hatred of the so-called
living gods of the Deva grew so strong
that he actively began plotting their
downfall around 1800 BCE ion's influence
among the lowest ranks of the empire was
inescapable he was charismatic he was a
slave he was powerful and he spoke of
violence of seizing daveite magic for
himself and using it to elevate himself
into Power ion's tenets and beliefs
appealed to the slave population who
also grew Hungry For Freedom ion's Creed
spread like wildfire and would form the
basis for all sarkic belief in the
centuries that came first there was
apotheosis Which ion was striving to
achieve and the path to doing so was the
will to power the next belief covered
that Concept in depth I unbelieved that
the will to power was the primary
driving force of man as an individual
seeks to master all things within its
domain they exert that power onto others
and others have the ability to exert it
back in opposition desire is the measure
of power and those with a stronger will
always triumph over the week the next
belief was the act of theophagy a
hypothetical tenet that ion was toying
with after observing the devite religion
for years theophagi referred to the act
of sacrificial consumption of a God and
upon eating them achieving
pharmaturgical reality bending and
all-powerful abilities there were many
gods in the universe and this ion knew
but none of them were fit for him to
worship instead he would crave their
power as a metaphorical example of
theophagy ion wanted nothing more than
to consume the devite Empire whole
taking its power for his own next there
was the idea of sacrifice whether it was
for the sacrifice of the self for the
benefit of many or the sacrifice of many
for the benefit of the individual ion
believed much like his Masters that
ritual sacrifice was a powerful tool
that could be used as a means to achieve
an end those who commanded the sacrifice
were showing their power bringing them
that much closer to apotheosis those who
were sacrificed were experiencing Strife
which would only make them stronger than
before muscles suffered damage but
eventually heal the Mind develops
Toleration against hardship such as
slavery this cycle of Destruction and
regeneration and strife was according to
ion one of the greatest tutors in the
natural world ion's final core belief
would be the most prominent outward
facing indicator of sarcasism and that
was the idea of shepherding the flesh
ion believed that all living things
descended from a single progenitor an
all-powerful God known as yaldaba who
the sarcasts would later regard as the
principal power in the universe
yadabath's relationship with sarkicism
tenuous at best with modern circuit
Cults either admiring or fearing the
enemy one thing is certain though
yadabath remains present in all sarcic
culture even if the religion doesn't
exactly worship the god itself yadavath
was a destroyer who fed upon Gods worlds
and stars who incidentally created the
entire universe and life itself as a
result of its power-hungry actions the
creation stories talk of yadavath as a
blind entity driven solely by Instinct
fueled by the forces of primordial chaos
as life was created as a result of
yadavat's existence it was ultimately
unguided by intelligence and its spread
throughout the Universe was similar to
that of a germ than anything Grand or
defined ion upon learning of these myths
came to the conclusion that the
Multiverse itself was only an altar that
held life's existence which was brought
into reality for the ultimate sacrifice
at the hands of yadavah the entity would
one day reclaim all of existence for
itself harvesting what it created and
consuming it whole as this was
yaldaboth's nature and purpose as the
ultimate being of the cosmos ion saw
this shared ancestry among life as the
key to genetic modification as all life
was derived from yadavath it held a
similar genetic code and it would become
the sarkic right to guide and cultivate
organic matter stealing the genes of
other life forms or creating entirely
new ones through this perversion of Life
ion felt he could ascend from something
ordinary to a living God fueled by the
unending cycle of sacrifice and Creation
with his radical power hungry beliefs
rapidly spreading throughout the David
Empire mostly among its slaves the
leading Deva became fearful of ion
attempts to assassinate him or use
serpion's influence were met with
failure and only fueled the mission of
his followers furthering the belief that
if they were to achieve godhood they had
to overthrow the devites who were the
most present all-powerful beings in
their lives this all came to a head when
ion launched his final act against the
David Empire after years of sowing the
seeds of disharmony and hate among the
slave population ion rallied his
followers and swept them up into a full
scale rebellion in a short time ion
overthrew the province he grew up in
fueled by The Rage of his followers who
mercilessly raised the city and
slaughtered the davites like animals
those who were present could see the
inscription ion brought to his followers
how he commanded them as if he were a
living God how he used the
reality-bending magic of the Deva and
turned it against them with his
followers utilizing anomalous Warfare in
a horrific gruesome way flesh was turned
into a weapon living beings were
contorted and transformed into
monstrosities and Abominations that
fueled the sarkic war machine devathama
turkey simply could not compete against
the permeating powerful and unrestricted
abilities of ion's followers before long
the city fell before the being who had
in that moment of bloodlust and fury
achieved apotheosis the being who was
now known as the grand karcissist ion
the Grand karcissist and his followers
rampaged through the ancient world
felling cities and entire Empires to
serve as stepping stones in their path
to godhood their weapons and armor were
unlike anything else at the time and
their utilization of powerful
flesh-bending magic made them
Unstoppable on the field of battle the
city of aditium was established as the
sarkic holy city where ion ruled as the
sorcerer King and as a living deity
texts from this period suggest that ion
had somehow usurped control of yadaboth
the Devourer itself wearing the Flesh of
the old God as a sort of armor and
crafting a kingdom from its body while
the depiction is most likely only a
metaphor for how much ion resembled
yadavoth in philosophy and pure power
the image of a living God devouring and
succeeding the old one is a striking
visual that surely empowered many
sarkists at the time another story from
sarkic mythology during this period is
the six ordeals of ion a parable that
told of six challenges that were issued
to ion by the archons the Servants of
yandemoth who challenge the newly
crowned king of aditum by enduring their
trials ion mastered the rituals
practices and beliefs ubiquitous to
sarcasism and broke free from the
bondage of mortal limitations but the
authenticity of this myth is debated and
the nature of the ordeals and ions
further relationship with yadavath
remains unknown but why did the Grand
karcissist Ion with his flowing red
robes and wielding his all-powerful
staff who Twisted flesh and drew blood
when he so much as Drew breath fall into
such obscurity that his religion remains
a mysterious and obscure footnote in the
foundation's archives if the sarkists
were as powerful as these early texts
state where are they today why did the
horrific city of aritam built of living
organic material that stood Monument to
ion's indomitable will fall in
sarkicism's golden age from 1600 and
1200 BCE the religion's permeation was
inescapable like the diseases they
wielded in their Wars sarcasism spread
like a contagion around the world
everywhere they went they assimilated
tribes and Villages into their ranks
fighting under the banner of aditum and
the sarkic faith this expanded Empire
would be referred to as kalmaktama or
the deathless many tried to defeat these
brutal Invaders including the king of
the hittite Empire himself but all fell
before them as the kalamaktama Empire
attempted to establish a foothold in the
Mediterranean invading and colonizing
the islands of Cyprus Crete and Gyros
for the first time in sarkic history the
tides of War began to turn against the
religion a coalition of Kingdoms were
formed in response to the sarkic threat
created by the Egyptians Greeks Minoans
canites Assyrians and most importantly
the mechanites who were the followers of
the Church of the broken God The Cult of
meccane the broken God had urged these
kingdoms to unite against the sarkic
threat and now United outfitted their
allies with Superior mechanite
technology
that anomalously enhanced the Empire's
War capabilities putting them on par
with the sarkic death Sorcerers and so a
great War was waged between the
kalmaktama Empire and the Coalition of
Kingdoms the details of such are largely
lost to time but the war itself was
fought with the full power of the
sarkists and the mechanites clashing
with one another and its consequences
left an imprint on the Earth itself a
death toll that estimates place at 20 to
30 million Mass Graves anomalous weapons
and even the deployment of giant
mechanical beings created by the
mechanites known as colossi that
rampaged through sarkic settlements and
cities though the battle was costly on
both sides the kalamaktama empire fell
to the Coalition and the once
impenetrable city of editum was
destroyed forever sarkicism would Fall
Into Obscurity and the Empire would be
forgotten possibly because it was much
easier than remembering the Horror's
ions subjected the world to the Grand
karcissist himself disappeared his
whereabouts unknown shortly after the
the fall of editum some said he had
ascended into godhood leaving the World
Behind others said he was slain in
battle nothing more than a man who
believed he would never die the sarkic
religion was effectively extinguished
from the world never to be seen again or
so that's what the Coalition was led to
believe though the Empire and editum
fell and ion disappeared an idea as
tantalizing and Powerful at sarcasism is
difficult to Snuff out entirely in
reality sarcasism would continue in
secret in both its Homeland in the urals
and among the offshoot tribes that had
fought under editum's Banner these sects
of sarcasism would practice their
beliefs in their war-ravaged Homeland
which suffered a great collapse
resulting in the fall of Kingdoms a
crisis of refugees the decline of art
literature Science and Technology
lingering disease and famine from
Psychic biological weapons spread even
to the kingdoms of the Coalition
resulting in an event historians refer
to as the late Bronze Age collapse the
Empire that was once deathless had now
fallen but its followers remained
practicing their power craving rituals
in secret and without centralization
this led to a sarcic dispora where
various sects and sarkic Cults each with
culturally distinct beliefs would crop
up throughout the Eurasian continent
while the foundation is unsure of the
specifics of these cult's activities and
beliefs elements of sarcasism would soon
begin to permeate the upper echelon of
society infiltrating Carpathian Cults or
sought out by Nobles themselves who
ignored the rumors of devil worship and
Witchcraft to seek out sarcic power for
their courts the tempting power that
sarkicism granted made it a popular
choice to be practiced in secret by
upper ranking Royals and even entire
noble families from their position of
power where they had access to knowledge
influence and a fresh supply of
sacrifices sarcasism endured over time
this would result in the formation of
sarkic great houses where families
practice their own interpretation of
sarkicism the religion that was now
mutated into hundreds upon hundreds of
variations and subcultures these great
houses would focus on individualism and
applying their powers to fulfill their
self-serving needs sarcasism now
decentralized completely would spread
throughout Europe via marriage as a high
society of Cults and magicians whose
true motives for ruling Their Kingdoms
and provinces were kept hidden behind
their meaty flesh curtain of absolute
secrecy today the sarkic Cults persist
and their anomalies are frequently
uncovered by the foundation
understanding them and their religion
however is another ordeal entirely and
the majority of sarkic History culture
and practices are unknown to the
organization but they're still out there
in the highest ranks of urban Society in
the most remote Villages of the world
there will always be those who crave to
wield flesh the followers of ion who
hope to achieve apotheosis however they
may believe they can do so though the
shells remain unclear there is one thing
the foundation has realized over its
years of studying the religion sarcasism
has and always will remain now go check
out
scp-3989 the bone Orchard and scp-610
the flesh that hates for more of those
squishy sarcasists